Ich nicht, san, sie. Ich bin gespannt, was sie sagen.
Der Kenner wird diesen Chorusdanken entgegengenommen haben und auch verstanden haben, welches Wort da gesungen wurde von diesen jungen Herren, die durchaus mit Stimmen ausgestattet sind. Ihr hört den Chaosradio Blue Moon und es geht heute Abend um und an dieser Stelle gebe ich natürlich sofort ab an Frank, Tim und Andreas.
Ich bin hier gerade mit meiner Lautstärkereinstellung ein bisschen am spielen.
Das ist auch ganz normal.
Ja.
Es geht um Spam, richtig?
Ja, du hast so recht. Also eigentlich geht es um die Vermeidung davon, beziehungsweise wie man das wieder los wird, wenn man sich einmal eingefangen hat. Da fällt mir ein, dass wir noch was ganz wichtiges, elementares vorher beginnen müssen. Du weißt schon.
Was, Bingo?
Dazu kommen wir auch noch. Nein, es fehlt einfach Hintergrundmusik. Aber nicht verzweifeln, dafür haben wir ja Computer.
Also für all diejenigen, die das nicht kennen, am Anfang jedes Chaosradio Blumens wird erst mal hochgebootet. So nennt man das. Und da kommt dann auch nichts Grundsätzliches raus. Es wird im Grund danach auch noch mal richtig angefangen, aber man unterhält sich so ein bisschen, sammelt sich privat und macht so was mit Musik. Es macht kleine Geräusche im Hintergrund, die sich anhören, als würde ein Mensch sie tun. Und dann irgendwann kommt man tatsächlich zur Sache. Aber ich werde auch erst mich zufriedengeben, wenn ich lustige Musik im Hintergrund höre.
Und da ist sie.
Gut, oder?
Ich bin stolz auf uns.
So, jetzt geht das auch einfach mal gleich viel.
Ich hab nichts zu bevorlesen hier.
Ich fühl mich so, als wären wir die vier Hauptdarsteller von Ocean's Eleven.
Oh, den hab ich noch nicht gesehen. Den mussten wir mal kurz erklären.
Wirklich cool. Ich werber dann vorher dafür, dass wir den Begriff Spam erklären, weil da geht es heute drum im Chaosradio Blue Moon um Spam. Was ist eigentlich Spam?
Spam ist ein Nahrungsmittel, ein englischsprachigen Raum. Und viele Leute nehmen das zu sich. Es ist besser bekannt unter dem Namen Sülze. Aber tatsächlich wollen wir natürlich hier nicht über Nahrungsmittel reden. Ich muss hier erstmal die ZD wegnehmen, damit ich dich auch sehen kann. Sondern es geht um, technisch ausgedrückt, unverlangte E-Mail. Wir sind uns sicher, dass ihr alle schon mal...
Great investment for foreign residents.
Irgendwo gelesen habt oder auch...
Auto enlarge your penis.
Sehr beliebt.
Oder wie ihr ganz schnell Geld machen könnt oder dass ihr sofort China zurückrufen sollt oder was auch immer. All die Dinge, die man eigentlich nicht wirklich tun möchte. Aber man wird halt permanent dazu aufgefordert. Und täglich, ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht, irgendwie seit einem halben Jahr nimmt es auf eine Art und Weise zu, dass es einen echt aufregen kann. Und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass Leute nicht in der Lage sind, ihre Mails-Software so einzustellen, dass das komplett an einem vorbeigleitet, dass sie irgendwann wahnsinnig werden.
Aber es ist schon eine Art von Fleißarbeit erforderlich. Weil du sagst, es ist jetzt so locker von der Hüfte weg, dass es einfach wäre, sein Mailprogramm so einzustellen. Man muss sich da schon ein bisschen Mühe geben.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass es einfach ist. Ich habe nur gesagt, dass es auf jeden Fall Leute gibt, die aber Schwierigkeiten haben, ohne jetzt zu mutmaßen, wie viele das sind. Aber es gibt definitiv Leute, die Schwierigkeiten damit haben, weil sogar ich habe damit Schwierigkeiten. Und ich weiß nicht, wie es euch geht.
Eigentlich Mailprogramm, dann ist es ja schon zu spät, wenn die Mail da ist. Du willst die Mail eigentlich vorher verhindern. Weil das Ärgerliche ist ja nicht nur, dass du die Mail in deiner Inbox hast, sondern dass irgendwie auch noch der Internet Traffic da irgendwie nicht belastet wird. Und mittlerweile, das sind Mengen. Ich weiß nicht, Zahlen gibt es wahrscheinlich keine.
Keine Zuverlässigen wahrscheinlich. Von 100 E-Mails, die ich kriege, würde ich sagen, sind 5 Spam. Also 5% ist bei mir locker der Threshold.
Ja, so ähnlich. Also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, dass das mit dem halben Jahr relativ plausibel klang, dass es vor einem halben Jahr so richtig angefangen hat. Weil ich da gemerkt habe, also privat ist bis jetzt noch nicht viel passiert bei den E-Mail-Accounts. Tatsächlich immer noch nicht. Aber hier beim ORB, unsere Internetadressen und unsere E-Mail-Adressen, die wir hier haben, die hat dann irgendwann Ende letzten Jahres mal jemand gescannt und seitdem kriegen wir permanent solche Sachen. Tina wants your feed und bla, nocken. Richtig, irgendwie so. Also in der Regel eklige Sachen. Und ist aber in der Regel vermischt mit meinem Konto, was ich bei Wired habe, wo ich immer irgendwelche News bekomme, die teilweise ebenfalls so strange Sachen in ihre Headlines reinschreiben, dass man denkt, es könnte auch Spam sein, wenn nicht Wired davor steht.
Achso, was denn zum Beispiel?
Ich vergesse das immer sofort wieder, weil es ist ja auch alles auf Englisch und da steht immer so was wie, who wants to knock my door zum Beispiel. Schreibt Wired dann so ein und man denkt sich, das könnte auch so ein Porno-Angebot sein, aber nein, es handelt sich um seriöse Information.
Take it from the backside.
Ja, take me from the backside. Deswegen ignoriere ich sowas mittlerweile komplett.
Kein Spam, ich hab hier nicht meinen Spam-Folder. Ich hab keinen Spam-Folder, ich schmeiß den immer weg.
Nicht wirklich. Dafür habe ich aber Kollegen, die sich regelmäßig damit beschäftigen und das sind immer sehr, sehr lustige Geschichten, vor allen Dingen wenn man daneben sitzt. Ich bin dazu übergegangen, mir immer Chips mitzubringen, wenn ich denke, okay, heute, wenn wir alle zwei Wochen eine Schicht haben, kommt ein Kollege und macht seinen Mail-Folder auf, hat irgendwie 110 neue Mails und dann steht da irgendwie so was halt wie Tina wants to lick your feet und dann kommt schon die Frage von links und da weiß ich schon Bescheid, fragt dann mein Kollege, ey, wer ist denn Tina? Weil ich hatte die Mail natürlich auch und dann denke ich so, pass auf, ich sag jetzt einfach mal den Namen Stefan, weil mein Kollege Stefan macht das immer falsch. Stefan, mach die Mail nicht auf. Moment mal, ich hab schon gedrückt, wer ist denn Tina? Und hier ist ja ein Link drin, ist ja geil. Seit wann sind denn in Mails Links drin? So, dann schaukelt sich das irgendwie hoch, bis er dann draufdrückt. Ich sag noch, pass auf Stefan, wenn du da jetzt draufdrückst, werden ungefähr acht Fenster aufgehen, die dich zubomben. Wenn du versuchst, die zuzumachen, werden nochmal acht Fenster aufgehen und du wirst es nicht raffen. Ey, aber wer ist Tina? Also vollkommen ausgeschaltet, das Gehirn ja. Drückt dann da drauf und in dem Moment geht acht Fenster auf. Und als ob ich das noch nicht gesagt hätte, sagt mein Kollege dann, ey Scheiße, das sind jetzt gerade ungefähr acht Fenster aufgegangen. Moment mal, hier steht überhaupt nicht Tina, hier steht jetzt Roberta. Was ist denn das für ein Beschiss? Man hat mir gesagt, hier kommt Tina. Und dann geht das ungefähr eine halbe Stunde, bis das alles wieder kommt. Zwei Wochen später beschwert er sich dann bei der EDV, dass er sagt, ey, hier ist alles im Arsch, ich kann keine Mails mehr empfunden, hier ist überhaupt nichts mehr. Was ist eigentlich mit meiner Einstellung los? Das zieht dann so seine Kreise. Also so viel zum Thema Spam und wie es das normale Leben beeinflussen kann.
Das ist ein Drama.
Ja, allerdings.
Das ist wirklich ein Drama. Und vor allem, es macht die Sache auch wirklich schwierig, weil ich hab schon so ein Spam-Auge entwickelt. Man kann die Dinger ja vollständig unscharf schon auf den Bildschirm schauen und man kann sie irgendwie erkennen. Es ist irgendwie so eine bestimmte Diktion, also man muss noch nicht mal das Wort richtig lesen.
Na, du weißt ja einfach, wenn eine vierstellige Zahl in der E-Mail...
HTML-Attachments sind auch mal schon irgendwie, entweder ist es Spam oder es ist wieder eine Bekannte, die sich gerade bei Hotmail einen neuen Account gemacht hat und noch gar nicht so richtig weiß, was man da eigentlich einzustellen hat. Und irgendwie athotmail.com klingt ja meistens auch mal schon ganz schön... Ich meine, wer weiß schon, was irgendwie jenny3974 athotmail.com ist. So, und dann hat man dann auch von Zeit zu Zeit, und das ärgert mich richtig, vielleicht sogar wirklich private Mails in seine Spamtonne geklopft und dann wird es eben wirklich anstrengend.
Du machst das automatisch oder per Filter?
Nein, mein Filter ist eher so, dass ich alles versuche, herauszufiltern, was relevant sein könnte, und das, was übrig bleibt, ist meist irrelevant. Und dann hab ich mein Spam-Filter, das ist die Taste. Katschack, schönes Gefühl. Wieder so, ah, wieder richtig Mail gelesen, um die 10.
Aber jetzt mal im Ernst, könnte man so einen Filter machen, weil es ja wirklich Tradition zu sein scheint, sich irgendwie Namen mit mindestens 5 Zahlen dahinter zu geben, wenn man Spam verschickt, dass man so sagt, wenn mindestens 2 oder 3 Zahlen am Stück in einer Mail-Adresse vorkommen, dann wird diese Mail automatisch weggeschmissen.
Ich kenne jemanden, der das macht und der ist da ganz glücklich mit, das geht. Aber es gibt mittlerweile noch bessere Unterscheidungsmerkmale, wenn nämlich irgendwie hinter dem Subject ein bisschen Platz ist und dann irgendwie in einen Buchstaben- oder Zahlencode kommt.
Genau, so EGG-Klammer auf, UY, DY, 8 EGG-Klammer zu.
Genau, und was es zu sagen hat, da kommen wir dann später noch zu.
Achso, aber mal vom Ansatz her, worum handelt es sich dabei eigentlich? Weil ist das jetzt tatsächlich sowas wie Wurfwerbung im klassischen Briefkasten? Ist das sowas wie, guckst dir an und ich möchte eigentlich wirklich ein Produkt verkaufen oder ich möchte, dass du dir bei mir deinen Penis verlängern lässt oder was auch immer? Oder ist das einfach sowas, was Traffic erzeugen soll und das Internet lahm macht?
Nee, das ist meistens einfach Porno und irgendwie die totale Massenware. Also wenn man so reinschaut, was sie verkaufen wollen, sie wollen irgendwie Antennen für Mobiltelefone, irgendwie Frauen oder Suchdienste oder Viagra verkaufen.
Herbe Viagra.
Na also meistens dreht es sich einfach um Porn. Also dieses Gehalt hat halt immer mit irgendwelchen glittigen, windigen Vorgängen zu tun.
Ich bekomme neuerdings auch so einen Wunsch nach Investmentfonds. Also wo ich Geld anlegen soll, das sind dann irgendwelche südafrikanischen Präsidenten oder der Weißpräsidenten. International Investment. Genau, International Investment. Das ist denn die How-to-make-dollar-dollar-fast-Variante. Akne-Mittel.
Akne-Mittel. Ja, so Pickle. Also die ganzen Sachen, wo die Leute vielleicht auch glauben, Internet wäre jetzt irgendwie genau der private Ort, wo sie das Problem endlich mal irgendwie beginnen zu lösen, weil sie sich in ihre Apotheke nicht trauen und sich im Internet nicht gerade wirklich gut aufgucken.
Pre-Register-Instructions.
Du möchtest doch das hier haben, oder? Free Naked Pics of Amateur Babes.
Amateur Babes, genau.
Von mar7856 at hotmail.com und es besteht natürlich ausschließlich aus HTML. Reply to testtera4 at hotmail.com Also die haben auch irgendwie einiges gelernt. Am Anfang sind sie noch relativ simpel dahergekommen. Und jetzt nutzen sie halt wirklich alles aus. Aufpoppende Fenster, seitdem das geht. Irgendwie hier dran an Speck. Und auch Webseiten, diese ganzen Porno-Webseiten.
Genau, wobei der neueste Trend sind jetzt nicht Pop-up, sondern Pop-under, wie ich gestern auf einer Party gelernt hab. Das sind Fenster, die nicht nach vorne poppen, sondern die im Hintergrund aufgehen. Also nicht aufgehen, sondern die verstecken sich in einer ganz kleinen Ecke und warten dann mit JavaScript einfach eine halbe Stunde und melden sich dann mal wieder. So, nach einer halben Stunde hast du natürlich auch überhaupt keine Ahnung mehr, was da irgendwie war, wo du jetzt gerade drauf hast. Und die da plötzlich auf und wieder ein Fenster, zack, zack, zack. Und dann bist du wieder voll dabei.
Meistens haben die ja sogar die Tendenz kurz zu erscheinen, vorne zu winken, so nach dem Motto, ich bin da. Und in dem Moment, in dem man kurz oben über dem Kreuzchen ist und es zu machen will, macht so ein Pfiff und sie sind weg. Und dann schalten sich zwei Fenster da vor, die das ablocken. Das ist fast von Sport, als würden sich so zwei Center da vorstellen, nicht?
Ja, das ist furchtbar. Also Spam ist wirklich eine der ekligsten und widerlichsten Sachen, die es gibt. Man muss diesen Leuten das Handwerk legen, wirklich, das ist schlimm. Aber das ist natürlich gerade so ein ganz trauriger Punkt. Es gab halt schon relativ früh im Netz eigentlich Gegenbewegungen. Spam wurde, sagen wir mal, von der Internetgemeinde schon als echt blödes Problem und nervig angesehen und auch, sagen wir mal, mit so einer gewissen, zumindest innerhalb der Szene einer recht breitbandigen Aktivität wurde dagegen vorgegangen. Ist natürlich alles abgeschmettert worden, weil eben solche angenehmen Institutionen wie zum Beispiel dieser Direktmarketing-Verband, wie heißt die noch gleich? Die dann irgendwie ja, und die Freiheit der Wirtschaft, und wir müssen doch werben, und wir müssen doch an die Kunden rankommen und blablabla, mit dem Ergebnis, dass halt die Politiker immer wieder eingeknickt sind und dass es nie wirklich mal ordentlich geregelt wurde. Ich meine, es ist einfach klar, ich will nicht Mails von irgendjemanden haben, wo ich sie nicht bestellt habe. Ganz einfach, weil wenn man da auch nur eine kleine Tür aufmacht und das Tor ist relativ groß, dann ist es einfach Ende. Dann kriegt man einfach E-Mails. Das nimmt dann irgendwie total überhand und führt dazu, dass der allerwichtigste Dienst des Internets komplett verstopft wird.
Im Prinzip verschiebt sich das ja. Früher gab es das, ich meine, es ist immer noch aktuell. Es gibt ja auch diesen Spam per Briefpost. Das ist jetzt nicht diese Hauswurf-Sendung, sondern wenn man vielleicht irgendwann mal aus einer Dummheit daraus ein Gewinnspiel mitgemacht hat oder irgendwo mal seine Daten hinterlassen hat, dann kann man auch ganz sicher sein, dass man irgendwann den Briefkasten voll hat. Und genauso ist es mit Spam eigentlich auch. Nur im Internet ist es für die meisten von uns auf jeden Fall noch schwieriger zu überblicken, wo sie denn ihre E-Mail-Adresse hinterlassen.
Haben die eigentlich mittlerweile was miteinander zu tun? Weil früher war das ja so, dass man sich zumindest den Spaß erlaubt hat, wenn man irgendwo seinen Namen oder seine Adresse hinterlassen hat, irgendwie einen Buchstaben falsch zu schreiben, groß zu schreiben, um dann zu gucken, wer wem die Daten verkauft. Gibt es sowas, dass das meinetwegen, dass man mal irgendwo bei einem klassischen Postding seine Adresse und seine E-Mail hinterlässt und die dann mittlerweile auch schon ans Internet verkaufen? Gibt es sowas schon oder haben die es noch nicht getroffen?
Ich habe das eine Weile lang so gemacht, dass ich irgendwie, wenn ich irgendwo Verträge unterschrieben habe und wie ich jetzt für wichtig hielt, mal irgendwie die Adresse, dann ist es halt nicht Hausnummer 23, sondern das ist Hausnummer 23a, die es nicht gibt. Deswegen kommt es immer an, aber man kann immer schön unterscheiden, wer jetzt eigentlich wem gerade mal diese Adresse gegeben hat.
Es geht auch mit dem zweiten Vornamen ganz gut.
Das ist auch keine schlechte Idee. Aber es kommt dann Internet eigentlich aufs gleiche raus. Auch da kann man sich natürlich beliebig viele Adressen machen, wenn man irgendwo eine hinterlässt. Das heißt, dass man sich jetzt auf irgendeinen Webmailer einträgt, wobei das auch so anstrengend geworden ist, wenn man ja erstmal 28 Seiten Formular ausfüllen muss über irgendwie jeden Scheiß, den sowieso kein Mensch richtig beantwortet.
Disclaimer.
Oder noch klüger, wenn man über eine eigene Domain verfügt, was eigentlich etwas ist, was man so haben sollte, wenn man ein bisschen damit umgehen sollte, weil es macht zwar ein bisschen Ärger, oder sagen wir mal, es macht zumindest ein bisschen Arbeit, aber es ermöglicht einem gerade beim Mail, wenn man ein bisschen fitter ist, sich da schon etwas angenehmer einzurichten. Zum Beispiel, warum sollte man nicht für jede Mailingliste, auf die man schreibt, eine eigene E-Mail-Adresse verwenden, die vielleicht den Namen dieser Mailingliste, also wofür man diese Mailbox benutzt, eben mit drin hat? Sagen wir, ich will mich halt auf irgendwie die Spamstoppers-Mailingliste machen, so dann habe ich irgendwie StampsML-Spamstoppers-Add und dann eben meine eigenen Domains, sodass wenn die Mail eben ankommt, meine Software in der Lage ist, das gleich korrekt einzusortieren auf der einen Seite. Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn ich von irgendwann mal Mail bekomme, an diese E-Mail-Adresse, dann weiß ich auf jeden Fall schon mal, was das Loch war.
Dann gibt es noch so die Kandidaten, die viel in Newsnet, also in den Newsgroups unterwegs sind, die haben dann so was wie Wegwerfadressen. Das sind Adressen, die benutzen sie genau einmal und dann nächsten Tag oder tageweise oder sowas, dann können sie das sehr gut sortieren. So dann ist es einfach nicht schlimm, wenn die sofort wieder aufgelöst werden oder irgendwie entsprechende Reaktionen auf den Mails, aber bei Domainen entfahren lassen.
Wobei das natürlich eine extreme Organisiertheit erfordert. Klar, du brauchst eine eigene Domain oder du musst halt irgendwie vom klassischen, der normale User ist das ja so, wenn er irgendwie nach einem halben Jahr aus Versehen dann mal sein Codewort nochmal eingeben muss, sein Passwort dann so, Scheiße, wie war das nochmal? Und dann die ganze Wohnung durchsucht wird nach dem Zettel, auf dem das steht. Mein Vater ist immer ein Garant für solche Anrufe mitten in der Nacht. Dieses Ding, sag mal, wenn ich bei T-Online und dann kommt irgendwie so ein Riemen und ich sag so, ja, da musst du diese beiden zahlen.
Was für Zahlen!
Ich habe jetzt schon die Schnauze voll, da wird er ja auch immer unheimlich fruchtig und hat auch überhaupt keinen Bock, sich darauf einzulassen.
Was kommt da ein Riemen?
Ein Riemen, ja, bei meinem Vater kommt immer ein Riemen. Ein Riemen ist einfach, ich weiß nicht, ob das was genuin-rheinländisches ist, auf jeden Fall immer ein...
Man kann auch ein Sermon sagen.
Kennt ihr einen Sermon?
Das ist mehr so die biblische.
Ein Sermon sozusagen, ein Lidl.
So ungefähr, ja.
Oder so ein...
Hä?
Also eine lange Argumentation, die auch gar nicht, die eigentlich komplett rhetorisch daherkommt. Das heißt, mein Vater hält sie mir vor, will eigentlich keine Antworten haben und nur brüllen kann, dass das doch alles scheiße ist. Bis ich dann am Ende hinten ansetzen kann, sage ich, pass auf, du trägst die Nummer da hin, die Nummer da hin und dann ist gut. Das ist, das ist...
Andreas, das ist gerade ein Fall für die Rolls-Bars-Taste hier.
Wir müssen hier mal Aufgaben verteilen.
Ich weiß nicht, was hier so amüsant daran war, dass ich dir irgendwie saure Bohnen hier hinlegen wollte, aber ich mach das jetzt einfach mal trotzdem. Du kannst übrigens wieder was gewinnen, wir haben einen Preis für dich.
Das ist schön.
Ja.
Ich hab auch was mitgebracht.
Du musst auch keinen Sermon anstimmen. Super.
Ich dachte, ich lass mich nicht umkaufen.
Was ist meine Kekse schon gerade im Wachsinn? Leute, kommt alle her.
Das ist das Tolle beim Chaosradio, dass man einerseits total explizite und dezidierte Informationen abgreifen kann, andererseits immer hört, wie andere Leute Süßigkeiten essen. Ja, das ist wichtig.
Geht jetzt eigentlich die Webcam?
Was ist denn da mit der Webcam?
Was ist überhaupt noch mal mit diesem Internet-Computer?
So, jetzt haben wir die zweite Phase beim Chaosradio. Wir tauchen wieder so ein bisschen ab in die eigenen technischen Gegebenheiten. Und wir haben ja diese Webcam hier bei Fritz auf www.fritz.de, die wir auf einen kleinen Aufkleber gerichtet haben für allejenigen, die überhaupt keine Webcam haben. Eine Webcam ist eine Art Kamera.
You don't have permission to access flash aktuell.
Du musst, glaube ich, den kleinen Satz ganz unten vorlesen, weil den kannst du auf der Kamera mit Sicherheit nicht erkennen.
Lasst die Leute das doch mal erklicken. Ich meine, vielleicht funktioniert das ja nur hier drin nicht. Das ist ehrlich gesagt meine Vermutung, dass es hier immer aus dem Cash kommt.
Das wäre eine Erklärung fürs klassische Fritz-Studio-Problem. Das funktioniert nur hier drin nicht.
Genau, ich trenne mal die Verbindung.
Vielleicht was zu diesem Aufkleber. Es handelt sich dabei um einen gelben Aufkleber, der euer Recht auf die Privatsphäre sichert. Und zwar eignet er sich wunderbar zum Aufkleben auf Kameraobjektive von Überwachungskameras. Das sind diese hässlichen, ekelhaften Dinger, die dich auf Schritt und Tritt verfolgen. Und wenn du eine Nase bohrst oder eine Runde Taschenbiljard spielst, dann ist das ganz unangenehm, weil du weißt, da sitzt jetzt garantiert jemand und lacht sich tot über dich.
Oder auch Schlimmeres.
Ja, freut sich drüber.
Und da gibt es dann beim Füllboot, das ist so ein Partnerverein vom CCC. Die haben ein paar Aufkleber gemacht und die könnt ihr da bestellen zum Beispiel. Und das ist immer praktisch so ein Päckchen davon, in der Tasche zu haben. Und wenn mal wieder so eine ganz, ganz ekelhafte Kamera ist, dann aber nicht kaputt machen die Kamera.
Wollen wir es jetzt tatsächlich damit hinter den Berg halten, was da jetzt genau drauf steht? Wir wollen warten, bis die User das erklicken, richtig?
Ja.
Wir können es doch einfach mal vorlesen. Ich meine, das ist die traditionelle Variante, ist im Radio relativ normal auch.
Wir müssen jetzt hier einen Zugang installieren.
Ey, das ist der Sinn mit euren Fahrtstriche hier.
Ihr habt ja hier den Oberspammer in eurem Buchmeld.
Genau, Frank Steffel, Powerpoint Steffel.
Oberspammer, der hat also wirklich in diesem Berliner Wahlkampf uns alle wirklich zum... Also gehört schon zu einer etwas unklugeren Aktion, irgendwie als CDU-Kandidat, das spitze Kandidat, dem Chaos Computer Club in Berlin irgendwie Spam zu schicken.
Das macht mir schon wirklich ganz schön dreif.
Und mit dem Foto auf der Webseite wird das sowieso alles.
Diese Fresse dazu, das ist wirklich unglaublich.
Und bei dieser Homepage... Du kannst was abspielen.
Nein, ich klicke da jetzt nicht drauf.
Nein, womöglich hat dieser PC auch noch eine Soundkarte. Ich meine, die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist ja relativ gering, aber...
Ich kenn das doch. Jetzt sitzen wieder geneigte Hörer, die sich eigentlich gedacht haben, sie würden sich gerne mal das erste Mal in ihrem Leben das Chaosradio wirklich anhören, sitzen zu zweit vorm Radio und dann dreht sich der eine jetzt nach fünf Minuten zum anderen um und sagt, die sind schon ein bisschen kindisch, oder?
Die sind schon kindisch, oder?
Das übertreibst du aber.
Ich hab's ja auch nicht gesagt. Das ist ja nur so eine Suggestionsgeschichte, nicht?
Dann machen wir mal lieber, warum eure Homepage nicht respondet, wenn ich schon frank schräg einwählen kann.
Ich hab mich eingewählt. Das Modem ist rot. Guck mal, da ist beides rot.
Ist das wirklich so, als hätten wir es?
Das Modem mit den Beißritzen müssen wir mit dem Modem einwählen.
Das hätte ich meinem Vater am Telefon.
Dass das rot ist, das heißt überhaupt nichts. Das heißt nicht, dass es was Schlimmes ist.
Jetzt blinkt es ja auch grün.
Ja, die blinken wir als Option. Es kommt nichts mehr. Keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich seid ihr gerade gedost worden oder die Spammer haben sich schon gerecht.
Hallo Tino.
Hallo.
Du, die Jungs machen ja hier Blödsinn.
Was ist mit dem Aufkleber?
Weißt du, worum es geht?
Ja, und da hab ich sowieso ein Problem. Und was geht darum? Ich hab, Moment. Ich habe, ich hole meine E-Mails nicht über ein E-Mail-Programm ab, sondern greife immer direkt auf die Seite zu, also auf den E-Mail-Anbieter.
Bei GMX oder?
Nee, ich hab Alta Vista. Und jetzt hab ich das Problem, dass, also ich krieg halt auch diese Nachrichten. Ich weiß jetzt einfach nicht, wie ich mich halt davor jetzt, oder was heißt, schütten kann. Ich hab es mit solchen Filtern versucht, aber das Problem war, dass ich dann dadurch auch andere E-Mails manchmal nicht gekriegt habe.
Genau. Was hast du denn eingetragen in deine Filter?
Sex und Tina.
Ich meine, wonach haben deine Filter deine eingehende Mail untersucht? Nach einem Wort, was in der Betreffzeile stand, oder nach Worten, die in der Mail stand?
Ja, also ich hab halt auch sehr viele, ja, das hatte ich zum Beispiel auch eingestellt. Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht mehr so genau, was das war. Also zum Beispiel hatte ich auch solche, um mich vor solchen Pausen Sachen zu schützen. Weil ich da wirklich auch solche Pausen Sachen auch wirklich davon gekriegt habe.
Und hast du sie auch angeklickt?
Ich hab sie auch mal aufgemacht. Aber also nur die Mails an sich, also die Links hab ich natürlich nicht.
Ach so, dann.
Nein, ich hab zum Beispiel auch ein bisschen, was das sollte, Gruß kaufen gekriegt von Leuten, die ich nicht kannte.
Waren das so Kettenbriefe, oder?
Jaja, also irgend so was vorwärts, ja.
Kettenbriefe sind ja auch was Tolles.
Dass irgendjemand ganz wichtig einen Organ braucht und diesmal ist es wirklich so, dass derjenige einen Organ braucht oder sowas, ne?
Genau. Diesmal sollst du wirklich deine Niere speichern.
Ja klar. Bestätigen sie uns, dass ihre E-Mail-Adresse in Benutzung ist. Das ist eigentlich die wahre Bedeutung dieser E-Mails. Also die Vortäuschung, irgendwelche Aktivitäten, die es vielleicht gar nicht gibt, einfach um die Leute dazu zu bringen, zu reagieren, damit gleichen sie dann ihre E-Mail-Datenbanken ab.
Wie viel Spam bekommst du denn so?
Also ich kriege in der Woche, wenn es hochkommt, so an die 20 Mails. Und davon, naja, ein Viertel sind bestimmt.
Sind was bestimmt? Ein Viertel? Ein Viertel von deiner ganzen Mail ist Spam? Wartest du?
Ja, also von denen, wenn es hochkommt.
Hast du denn eine Idee, wo der Spam herkommt? Also ich meine, wie die an deine Adresse gekommen sind?
Also es gibt ein paar andere Services, hier zum Beispiel jetzt Online-Shopping oder so, wo wir uns auch angemeldet haben. Und da ist es ja sowieso nicht ganz sicher, ob die denn nun die Sachen an die dritte Person weitergeben. Und also kann ich mir vorstellen, dass naja gut, ob die nun mit Problems haben oder was weiß ich, in Verbindung stehen, jedenfalls krieg ich da halt so eine Dinger.
Nein, in der Regel ist es einfach so, dass sie den kompletten Adressdatensatz verkaufen. Das macht ja auch jedes beliebige Kaufhaus, bei dem du einen Katalog bestellst, die verkaufen das an Adresshändler und die wiederum verkaufen das an beliebige andere Drittanbieter. Das gibt Adresshändler, die machen auch richtig gutes Geld.
Übrigens geben mittlerweile die Kreditkartenunternehmen ganz offen zu, dass sie den größeren Umsatz oder zumindest den größeren Gewinn auf jeden Fall schon mit der Vermarktung von Kundenprofilen machen. Also jetzt nicht über den Kundendaten, aber auf jeden Fall den Kundenprofilen. Also die Leute, die gekauft haben, kaufen auch oft.
Deswegen geht doch jetzt auch Visa mit Payback zusammen oder so.
Genau, richtig, schönes Beispiel.
Tino, ich weiß, du wolltest wahrscheinlich eher eine Antwort auf deine Frage haben und jetzt schwirren in deinem Hirn stattdessen noch fünf Fragen mehr rum. Aber ich hoffe, dass dir innerhalb des Chaosradio Blohmuns beantwortet werden bis um eins. Vielleicht einfach weiter zuhören?
Wenn Fritz rund um Cottbus, dann 103, 2.
Die Uhrzeit mittlerweile 22 Uhr 33 Minuten. Na komm, du Kleine. Ach, das ist eine... Tatsächlich, wenn das Chaosradio im Haus ist, funktionieren auch alle anderen Sachen nicht.
Das ist eine lustige Geschichte.
Zudessen noch ein bisschen Musik im Hintergrund. Wir relaxen kurz, fragen uns, warum die MUD nicht eingestellt ist. Das muss an mir liegen, aber mein Gott, man kann ja nicht alles können. Bastian Berner ist übrigens schon im Studio. Ich mach hier gerade was für dich bereit. Ich hoffe, du kutierst das wenigstens ein bisschen. Mit dem Wetter nachts vorübergehend gering bewölkt und es wird sich abkühlen auf 3 bis 0 Grad. Morgens anfangs gebietsweise Regen oder Schneeregen, später wieder Schauer bei 6 bis 9 Grad.
Die Unions-Bundestagsfraktion hat sich mit großer Mehrheit gegen den Kompromissvorschlag der rot-grünen Bundesregierung zum Zuwanderungsgesetz ausgesprochen. Auf einer Sondersitzung gab es am Abend allerdings 3 Gegenstimmen. Der Innenausschuss des Bundestages hatte den Entwurf für das Zuwanderungsgesetz zuvor gebellicht. Der frühere brandenburgische Bauminister Wolf ist zu 5 Jahren Haft verurteilt worden. Das Potsdamer Landgericht sah es als Erwiesen an, dass Wolf seine Ehefrau ermorden lassen wollte. Saudi-Arabien hat die Europäische Union um Unterstützung für seinen Nahost-Friedensplan gebeten. Kronprinz Abdullah informierte heute in Schieda den außenpolitischen EU-Beauftragten zu Lana über Einzelheiten des Vorschlags. Erstmals erhalten Drogenabhängige in Deutschland offiziell und unter ärztlicher Aufsicht Heroin. In Bonn eröffnete heute die Drogenbeauftragte der Bundesregierung Casper's Merck eine Heroinambulanz. In der Affäre um die Bankgesellschaft Berlin sind die ehemaligen AUBIS-Geschäftsführer Neuling und Wienholt erneut festgenommen worden. Beide wurden am Nachmittag dem Haftrichter vorgeführt. Es bestehe Fluchtgefahr, hieß es. Nach mehr als 50 Jahren geht die Ära der D-Mark morgen zu Ende. Gezahlt werden kann nach dem 28. Februar nur noch mit Euro. Auch in den meisten anderen Euro-Staaten verlieren die alten Münzen und scheinen ihre Gültigkeit. Und zum Sport in der Deutschen Eishockeyliga verloren die Eisbären Berlin in München 3 zu 4 nach Penalty-Schießen. Und es liegen keine aktuellen Meldungen zum Verkehr vor.
Nee, diesen Sonntag.
Du, ich hab ne ganz schlechte...
Jan Plefka kommt. Ja, der Ex-Sänger von Selig.
Nein, der hat doch jetzt ne neue...
Der hat ne neue Band.
Natürlich spielen die.
Rocco Klein?
Ja, der hat auch zugesagt. Nein, der ist doch nicht mehr bei Viva 2. Viva 2 gibt es doch gar nicht mehr.
Komm einfach vorbei am Sonntag und dein...
Ja, ist gerettet, Ted.
Du, ich muss Schluss machen, ja?
Und im Radio, Fritz.
So viel dazu, warum die britische Komikertruppe Monty Python schon damals und heute noch als Visionär gilt, weil die antizipiert haben, dass es heute im Chaosradio um Spam geht und das wahrscheinlich nicht das ist, wovon die gesungen haben, aber grundsätzlich nicht I don't want Spam! schon die Grundaussage hat, die richtig ist. Kollegen, aber bevor wir wieder zu dem Thema kommen, was ist denn eigentlich, und diese Frage liegt mir ja immer spontan auf der Zunge, abends wenn ich ins Bett gehe fast regelmäßig, was ist denn eigentlich mit Blinken Lights?
Tim, du meinst das Haus?
Glaube ich ja, ich glaube ich mein das Haus.
Das ist aus.
Das Haus in Berlin, wo man, du weißt schon, wo man seine Freundin einladen konnte und wo man dann auf den Alexanderplatz ging und dann hat man eine Nummer gewählt und dann kam da so eine Animation, da kam so was wie ich liebe dich und dann war die Freundin hin und weg und hat gesagt ich will dich heiraten und dann hat man diese Kinder gemacht und dann war man auf einmal verwickelt und dachte sich verdammte Scheiße und dann diese ganzen Komplikationen und da blinken lights halt.
Ja, es ist ausgeschaltet, es hat sich ausgeblinkt.
Ach komm.
Also wir haben, naja, es wurde Zeit. Also das Haus wird jetzt saniert und dazu musste man das halt abbauen, weil das ging dann halt nicht so richtig mit einer Baustelle zusammen und das ist eigentlich auch ziemlich lange und erfolgreich gelaufen. Übrigens genau 23 Wochen und 5 Tage. Und am 23. also am letzten Samstag, war die letzte Nacht und dann haben wir noch ein bisschen gefeiert und sind auch noch ein paar Leute vorbeigekommen, haben mitgefeiert. Ja und dann ist es jetzt ausgeblinkt.
Gibt es noch eine klassische, für den Fall, dass ihr Blinkenlights nicht mitbekommen habt, könnt ihr hier noch mal alles nachlesen, Blinkenlights-Webseite?
Blinkenlights.de Naheliegend. Nicht Blinking, sondern Blinken. Und dann seid ihr eigentlich schon auf der richtigen, also wer das nicht hin getippt bekommt, muss es mit ccc.de probieren, da gibt es auch noch mal so ein Haus drauf. Ja, da findet sich auch noch so das ein oder andere, das ist auch noch nicht alles noch nicht ganz zu Ende. Wir haben ja vor, den Source Code von der Blinkenlights-Controlsoftware als freie Software ins Netz zu stellen. Haben vor, weil wir da natürlich noch mal ein bisschen aufräumen müssen, damit es nicht so peinlich ist. Und dann könnt ihr euch irgendwie euer eigenes Hochhaus nehmen und das damit irgendwie beleuchten, insofern es irgendwie über die richtigen Parameter verfügt. Und es sind auch noch ein paar Sachen dazugekommen in den letzten Monaten, die ganz nett sind. Zum Beispiel einen Blinkenlights-Simulator, mit dem man irgendwie auf dem Linux-Rechner im Prinzip den schönen View, so wie man ihn auf diesen Preview-Bildern immer gehabt hat. Da kann man ja irgendwie seine eigenen Playlists drauf fahren, also im Prinzip genau das Gleiche tun, was wir eben mit dem Haus gemacht haben.
Wann kommt das Gameboy-Spiel?
Wir sind ja in unseren internationalen Merchandising-Bemühungen nicht so weit.
Na, das gibt es für den I-Pack, nicht als Spiel, also nicht interaktiv, oder ich weiß gar nicht. Ist es sogar interaktiv, das Point? Das wäre doch eigentlich das, was wir noch machen.
Das ist bisher nur ein Player, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe.
Es gab einen Wettbewerb für die schönsten Filme und da gab es Preise. Und diese Preise waren bestanden aus diesen kleinen Mobilcomputern.
I-Packs, von I-Pack. Genau. PC ist im Prinzip nicht wirklich ein Mobilcomputer, aber ein PC auf mobilen Bedarf hingeschneidert. Eigentlich ganz nette Maschinen mit bunten Bildschirmen. Und auch da drauf läuft ein Blinkenlides-Player. Das ist erstmal so gehackt. Und dann gibt es vielleicht auch noch ein Screen-Zelver. Blinkenlides, Blinkenlides, Blinkenlides.
Blinkenlides, Blinkenlides, Blinkenlides.de Damit könnten wir natürlich auch direkt wieder zum Thema zurückkommen des heutigen Abends in meinem Chaosradio Blue Moon Spam.
Werteeinblendung.
Gesetzliche Grundlagen. Was man machen kann. Und wie das aussieht und wie überhaupt die Regelungen sind. Und hin und her und der ganze Kram, den der Normalbürger nicht kennt und nur hier von euch erfahren kann. Wie siehts da aus?
Scheiße. Klar und kurz zu sagen. Es gibt in Japan, haben sie sich dann doch dazu durchgerungen, dass dieser Spam irgendwie gekennzeichnet werden muss. Ich glaube es ist in Amerika auch so. Dann habe ich hier was, also eigentlich finden das alle irgendwie blöd, aber so richtig zu durchringen, können sie sich nicht, weil da gibt es ja nämlich auch noch so eine Industrielobby oder zumindest eine Wirtschaftslobby, wie gesagt der DMMV, also der Direktmarketingverband. Und die finden Spam natürlich ganz toll.
Weil man muss ja zu den Kunden kommen.
Genau.
Wenn die Kunden schon nicht zu einem kommen, muss man sie noch heim suchen.
Dieser DMV, der filiert nun schon mal, ist das irgendwie so eine halbseitende Veranstaltung?
Das ist einfach so ein Lobbyverband. Da sitzen halt diese ganzen Direktmailer und vergleichbare Bewerber, Anrufer.
Und dann gibt es den Multimediaverband. Wie hießen die denn? War das nicht auch was mit irgendwie MMV? Es gab noch so einen Multimediaverband. Wann waren die das? Vielleicht haben wir jetzt jemanden verheilt, das ist irgendwie... Aber ich glaube der Direktmarketingverband ist das.
Der Direktmarketingverband ist auf jeden Fall ganz vorne. Und da gibt es auch noch diverse andere internationale Unternehmungen, die das halt alles erstmal ganz wichtig finden. Weil man darf ja die freie Wirtschaft, die sogenannte freie Wirtschaft, davon ja nicht behindern. Airbus, das führt, denke ich, nicht unbedingt zu mehr irgendwie Verständnis für sein... das Unternehmen so als Kunde, sondern man fühlt sich eigentlich ganz schön angekackt. Mir geht es zumindest so und ich denke, es geht dem meisten auch so, weil... Ich bevorzuge es natürlich auf jeden Fall, wenn jemand auf Anforderungen mit mir in Kontakt treppelt. Das sind viele Leute, das zeigt ja auch deine Geschichte, reflektieren das irgendwie gar nicht. Deswegen wäre so eine gesetzliche Regelung eigentlich schon mal ganz... von Vorteil. Was gab es denn bisher?
Na, ich wollte mal grad erklären, dass wenn um diese Spam-Geschichten und so was unerwünschte Werbung diskutiert wird, dann gibt es da im Wesentlichen zwei Begriffe. Die wichtigsten sind das eine ist die Opt-in-Variante und das andere ist die Opt-out-Variante. Und die Opt-out-Variante besagt, dass sie mich erstmal komplett zu spammen dürfen, so lange bis ich nein sage. Und die Opt-in-Variante ist, dass sie mich erst dann zu spammen dürfen, wenn ich ja sage. Das ist ein ganz erheblicher Unterschied, ob ich aktiv zustimme oder einfach das erkennt ja im Wesentlichen daran, dass das irgendwie besonders gekenntlich gemacht wird. Das heißt, ich muss irgendwie hier ein Hickchen machen, so nein, ich will irgendwie keine Werbung. Und die gute Variante wäre, dass ich ein Hickchen machen muss, ja, ich will Werbung. Das kann ich ja nämlich nicht aus Versehen vergessen. Und das ist das, was ich so in Deutschland unter den seriösen Betrieben bei Verträgen oder bei irgendwelchen Anmeldegeschichten irgendwie so durchgesetzt hat und wie es eigentlich auch die Datenschutzbeauftragten für in Ordnung befinden. Aber das hat sich halt noch nicht ganz so rumgesprochen, leider. Die EU tut sich ein bisschen schwerer mit. Das geht immer so hin und her. Ich weiß nicht, Andreas, hast du da ein bisschen was?
Jo, ich kann einfach mal anfangen mit früher war alles besser, wie immer im Leben. Früher gab es in Deutschland Rechtsprechungen schon 1997 zum Thema E-Mail und unverlangte E-Mail. Und warum halt das hier so?
Ist nur eine Täuschung.
Die da besagt hat, das unverlangte Schicken von Werbematerial an private E-Mail-Adressen ist wettbewerbswidrig. Da gibt es das UWG, das Gesetz gegen den unlauteren Wettbewerb. Und das Landgericht Berlin, das Amtsgericht Brackel, noch mal das Landgericht Berlin, das Landgericht Traunstein und hab ich vor mir liegen, haben alle entschieden, das Schicken von Werbematerial ohne vorherige Einwilligung, also Obdout-Spam, wettbewerbswidriges und einen Unterlassungsanspruch begründet. Dann kam die EU und hat eine Fernabsatzrichtlinie erfunden, die da besagt, wir wollen jetzt Waren in Zukunft auch übers Internet vertreiben. Und damit das funktioniert, müssen wir die Leute ja anschreiben können und dann möchten wir ihnen auch Spam schicken dürfen. Das ist noch nicht ganz korrekt. Es gibt da einen Erwägungsgrund, in dem sie sagen, grundsätzlich autorisiert die Richtlinie niemanden, mich voll zu spammen, aber die Mitgliedsländer können das explizit beim Erlassen der Richtlinie tun. Und das haben sie meines Wissens auch in Deutschland getan. Und somit gibt es momentan eigentlich keinen wirklichen gesetzlichen Unterlassungsanspruch gegenüber Spam. Davon abgesehen ist es ja auch immer ein technisches Problem, das dann durchzusetzen. Schließlich weiß ich nicht, woher der Spamer kommt, wo er denn sitzt und ob er überhaupt deutschem Recht unterliegt.
Seiden es sind so dreiste Sachen wie Powerpoint Steffel.
Seiden es sind so dreiste Dinge wie Powerpoint Steffel.
Powerpoint Steffel ist ja nicht noch von Microsoft irgendwie. Haben die sich nicht noch beschwert durch die Verwendung dieses Namens?
Ich hab das mal gerade in meinem Mailfolder.
Ich glaube ja. Ich glaube die haben ja klar, das haben die sich nicht entgehen lassen.
Wollte dich nicht...
Ja, Powerpoint Steffel, bei dem wir uns immer fragen, Stank Steffel, hat leider dann auch unseren Forderungen um Unterlassung nicht Folge geleistet und so weiter Spam geschickt, bis wir ihn mithilfe einer technischen Maßnahme, nämlich einem Filter ausgetragen haben. Hier sieht man auch das Problem, um Leute technisch filtern zu können, muss man irgendwelche Filterkriterien haben. Dazu kann man alle Dinge filtern, die das Subject Make Money Fast beinhalten. Das geht noch relativ einfach. Man kann sich auch dazu hinreißen lassen, alles zu filtern, was Dollar im Betreff hat, dann wird es schon schwerer. Oder man wirft Mails weg, die von Mail-Adressen kommen, die ein oder mehrere Ziffern beinhalten. Dann bekommt man weder von seinen Freundinnen bei Hotmail, noch von den Mitarbeitern der Büros des Deutschen Bundestages Post, weil die auch unpraktische Mail-Adressen haben. Und naja, ist alles ein Elend, das sieht man hier schon ganz gut. Aber man kann natürlich technisch filtern, und wie das geht, kommen wir vielleicht hoffentlich noch dazu.
Ja, also mit der EU geht das immer ein bisschen in den Herd. Ich hatte hier irgendwie Sachen von Januar 2001, da war es gerade mal wieder bei Opt-in, also Pro-Spamming. Dann im Juli 2001 hat sich der Ausschuss für Bürgerrechte eindeutig gegen Spam ausgesprochen, wobei ich nicht weiß, welche Wirkung das da gehabt haben könnte. Und das geht eigentlich immer hin und her. Und so richtig ganz doll durchringen, konnten die sich da auch noch nicht eine klare Ansage zu machen. Aber in Deutschland ist es so weitestgehend anerkannt, dass Spam eigentlich böse ist. Zu dieser wettbewerbsrechtlichen Geschichte, ist vielleicht noch zu sagen, dass es eine reine Unterlassungssache ist. Das heißt also, ich muss mir denn auch einen Anwalt suchen oder möglicherweise auch einen konkreten Schaden geltend machen. Und wenn ich jetzt gegen eine Spam-Mail da einen konkreten Schaden, der ist vielleicht nicht mal im Pfennigbereich normalerweise, sei denn ich habe jetzt einen besonders großen Aufwand mit. Und da macht sich natürlich auch kein Anwalt die Mühe, da auch nur den Telefonheurer abzunehmen, um da was zu machen, irgendwelche Verfügung zu schreiben, sei denn klar, ich will es irgendwie bezahlen. Aber dann ist es wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal verhältnismäßig und ich habe da irgendwie ganz schlechte Karten. Und ein Richter beschäftigt sich in der Regel schon gar nicht damit.
Mal eine praktische Frage. Sind die, da das momentan EU-weit noch sozusagen Grauzone ist, damit aus dem Schneider, wenn sie unten hinschreiben, wenn du keinen weiteren Spam mehr haben willst, klicke bitte hier bzw. schreibt eine Mail, blablabla?
Los nicht.
Das ist nicht okay?
Nein, also der Trick dabei ist, wenn man da draufklickt, dann wird diese Mail-Adresse als Götig zurückgemeldet und dann steigert sie im Wert. Das heißt, wenn du einmal draufklickst, steigert die Mail-Adresse den entsprechenden Wert.
Okay.
So ist es bestätigt worden. Möglicherweise wird es bei dem Anbieter oder bei dem Spammer ausgetragen, das kann gut sein, nur der verkauft sie dann entsprechend weiter oder benutzt bei seinem nächsten Mailing wieder neu oder wie auch immer.
Ein Teufelskreis sozusagen. Gibt es Anrufer? Es gibt Anrufer, tatsächlich. Und zwar eine Menge. 03.73.97.9110 ist die Nummer für den Fall, dass ihr Erfahrungen mit Spam gemacht habt oder was über Spam wissen wollt. Oder Spam-Spezialisten seid, weil wir im Laufe des Abends auch auf den Punkt kommen wollen, dass wir wissen, wie wir unseren Browser richtig einstellen in Filtersachen.
Mail-Admins würde ich ja gerne mal hören irgendwie. Ob es Mail-Admins gibt, die sozusagen in ihrem operativen Bereich gegen Spam vorgehen und wie sie das tun und ob sie das mit Erfolg tun.
Hi.
Hi. Ja, ich bekomme auch sehr oft Spam. Und muss auch das bestätigen, was hier gerade gesagt wurde, dass wenn man diese versucht zu remoten, also dass man sie nicht hinbekommt, dass man dann, das dauert nicht lang, dann kriegt man nochmal welche. Und mir ist dann aufgefallen, ich hab dann von derselben Firma auf einmal zwei E-Mails bekommen. Einmal für uns, was ich für uns in den Bank kam. Und dann noch eine andere Sache. Eine Sache, die in den pornografischen Bereich ging. Und finde ich schon ziemlich heftig vor allem. Ich finde es bescheuert, weil ich weiß nicht, was ich dagegen machen kann. Ich bin in dem Sinne nur ein einfacher Webmaster, der die Webseiten programmiert, aber nichts mit Internet-E-Mails zu tun hat. Der einfach nur seine E-Mails abfragt. Mehr hab ich nicht damit zu tun. Und ich würde natürlich auch gerne wissen, wie ich solche Sachen blocken kann. Was mich nervt ist, dass ich, wenn ich im Monat so 10-20 E-Mails bekomme, wenn ich die dauernd lösen muss und wenn ich das dauernd wieder dauert, nicht lang krieg ich 4-Weite. Das nervt.
Hast du dir schon mal so ein Mail herangeguckt?
Was verwendest du für Software, um deine Mail zu lesen?
Also angemeldet bin ich einmal bei Web.de und dann bei GMX. Und Web.de hole ich auch über Web ab. Und ansonsten über den Express Office hier. Genau.
Outlook Express. Auf dem Mac oder auf dem PC?
Auf dem Windows, also Windows Rechner. Und ich meine, da geht es ja noch ganz gut, nur ganz schnell zu löcheln, weil da klicke ich einfach nur einmal auf die Läden, dann verfracht der diese Mail ja in die Löchtenordner. Und den löche ich auch regelmäßig. Aber trotzdem ist das nervig, immer so eine Mail zu haben.
Also bei Outlook Express und anderen E-Mail-Programmen kann man heutzutage in der Regel Filter einrichten. Bist du damit vertraut?
Ja, ähm, nee, nicht unbedingt.
Also Filter heißt einfach, es handelt sich um die Software, dein Mail-Programm, schaut sich die Mail in dem Moment, wo sie sie empfängt, beziehungsweise in dem Moment, wo sie sie in deine Eingangsordner einsortiert, schaut sie sich die Mail an. Und du kannst sozusagen Parameter angeben, kannst es einstellen, was diese Software, was dein Mail-Programm zu dem Zeitpunkt tun soll. Zum Beispiel, du kannst irgendwie anschauen, von wem kommt das. Also ist es von der und der E-Mail-Adresse. Das funktioniert in der Regel nicht so, weil die Spammer fast mit jeder Mail eine neue E-Mail-Adresse verwenden. Die haben irgendeinen Basisnamen und zählen hinten halt 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 Stellen durch. Das hilft wenig. Du kannst dann auch, sagen wir mal, nach bestimmten Inhalten vorgehen. Das heißt, du kannst typische Sätze wie Make Money Fast und so weiter rausholen. Das ist halt immer kritisch, weil es auch durchaus mal sein kann, dass jemand irgendwie dir das vorwortet, also dir sozusagen eine solche Mail weiter schickt, das Subject beibehält, aber noch einen persönlichen Kommentar dazu schreibt, ob der dann jetzt für einen wichtig ist oder nicht. Das ist ja eine andere Sache, aber es handelt sich an dem Moment eben nicht mehr um Spam, eigentlich einen Sinne, sondern um eine private Mail.
Ja, was ich mal gemacht hatte, war, dass ich bei GameX, doch mal bei Outlook angegeben habe, also das und das halt ignorieren, löchen. Das habe ich schon mal gemacht gehabt. Ich wusste erst nicht, was ihr meint am Anfang. Und dann hatte ich auch schon mal gesagt, okay, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie ich das gemacht habe, aber irgendwie hat er dann alle englischen E-Mails gelöscht. Für mich natürlich auch problematisch, da ich ab und zu ihn mit aus England bekomme und auch Amerika. Das ist halt auch so, dass die auch gelöscht werden. Das ist natürlich unpraktisch.
Deswegen ist es generell zu empfehlen, eigentlich eine Mailsoftware zu benutzen, die auf dem eigenen Computer läuft und die Mail letztlich auch auf dem eigenen Computer speichert, also komplett herunterlädt.
Was empfehlt ihr denn da?
Nicht Outlook. Na es gibt da zum Beispiel Eudora.
Eudora ist ein ganz guter Tipp. Eudora geht sehr zurückhaltend um.
Haben wir nicht das herunterladen irgendwo?
Eudora gibt es in einer freien Version. Dann wird diese Werbung ein.
Es gibt eine ganz light Version.
Die blendet Werbung ein, damit hast du nichts gewonnen.
Nein, stimmt es genau.
Die light Version ist frei, ohne Werbung.
Genau, dann gibt es die voll Version mit Werbung oder die voll Version ohne Werbung mit Bezahlung.
Und nur die kostet Geld, genau. Also Eudora ist eigentlich ein...
Wobei ich bin da ein bisschen angepisst in der letzten Zeit. Die haben da irgendwas vergeigt mit der neuen Version. Ich würde vielleicht lieber eher The Bad empfehlen. Das ist auch ein ganz kleiner, schnuckeliger Mailer. Kann irgendwie auch alles. Und geht auch sehr behutsam mit den Mails um. Das heißt, es führt kein HTML-Code und so einen Quatsch aus. Gibt es noch Pegasus eigentlich noch? Genau, das ist auch ein alter Klassiker.
Pegasus kommt doch immer mit den Encodings nicht klar. Naja, es ist schwierig, E-Mails auch für Windows zu empfehlen, weil die irgendwie auch alle so ein bisschen unter der Microsoft-Frucht manchmal hängen und irgendwie ähnliche Features implementieren müssen, um konkurrieren zu können. Naja, doch schon, sie müssen irgendwie HTML anzeigen und den ganzen Schnarz. Und irgendwann werden sie auch JavaScript können. Das ist alles ein Elend. Eudora ist relativ to the bones.
Aber hast du dein Computer jetzt vor dir? Ah, sonst hättest du mal nach den Mailheadern gucken können.
Moment, es kann dauern bei mir nicht lange.
Nee, wir machen das in einer Online-Moment.
Generell ist es halt so, die Mail enthält eine Betreffzeile, sie enthält Inhalt und sie enthält auch weitere Header. Die Betreffzeile ist nur einer davon. Naja, so oben, viele Mailprogramme zeigen das ja auch genauso an, wie es drin steht. Da steht da irgendwie From, Doppelpunkt und die E-Mail-Adresse von wem das kommt und Tour Doppelpunkt, wohin es geschickt wurde und andere Sachen wie CC. Bloß die Header, die ein E-Mail-Programm einen normalerweise anzeigt, sind nicht unbedingt alle, sondern in der Regel gibt es noch deutlich mehr, die darüber Auskunft geben, woher die Mail kommt, welche Computer diese Mail einmal angefasst haben, um sie dir zuzustellen. Teilweise findet man auch Informationen darüber, welche Software diese Mail verschickt hat, auch weitergeleitet hat und ähnliche Dinge.
Ja, ich habe vorhin angesprochen, dass solche Sachen auch verkauft werden, solche E-Mail-Adressen. Ich möchte auch mal so sagen, ich habe auch manchmal, weiß nicht, irgendwo Newsletter abonniert, das ist auch der Gag, dann zeigen die die ganzen E-Mail-Adressennamen an, wo es hingesendet wurde. Das heißt, da sind manchmal um die 100 E-Mail-Adressen drin und wenn jemand also nicht nur das Newsletter haben wird, sondern auch ein paar E-Mail-Adressen, dann kriegt er die da, ohne mal was zu bezahlen, sondern ganz einfach und kann mit dem machen, was er will.
Das ist eine besonders ausgeprägte Dummheit, die viele Leute machen, vor allem im privaten Bereich, meist aus Unkenntnis. Es gibt halt zwei header, die man benutzen kann, um weitere Leute als Empfänger zu markieren. Also entweder man schreibt sie alle ins Tor, das ist schon mal ziemlich dumm. Oder man nimmt sie halt ins CC, das ist auch noch recht dumm. Dann gibt es noch die besondere Variante Blind Carbon Copy, BCC. BCC ist sozusagen das, was man verwenden sollte, wenn man eine Mail an viele Leute, die nicht unbedingt voneinander wissen müssen, schicken möchte.
Wobei Tatsache ist, habe ich gemerkt, ich habe mir mal ein paar E-Mails kleines angeschaut, dass BCC ganz oft gar nicht mehr als Option gegeben ist. Also nur noch CC eingetragen ist und BCC muss man wirklich mit der Lupe nachsuchen.
Wir müssen die User ja nicht verwirren, das wäre dann schon zu viel. Die Leute wissen nicht, was sie da eintragen sollen.
Ja, darauf sollte man achten. Da ist man bei solchen etablierten, alten Programmen wie Eudora immer gut bedient. So ein Feature wäre, die da niemals rausnehmen. Neuere, kleines Verhalten versuchen manchmal alles zu vereinfachen und machen dadurch noch alles schlimmer.
Ich bin jetzt hier gerade mal bei Outlook Extras drin.
Mach mal auf, genau, mach mal eine Mail auf.
Ja, hab ich. Also im Moment muss ich ganz oben öffnen. Ja, hab ich. Hier ist zum Beispiel auch, jetzt hab ich es geöffnet über den Fenster und dann steht da auch von utun8034. Und dann ging es irgendwie erstmal an www.budpirate998.yahoo.com und dann stehen hier halt die ganzen in Finger. Ich weiß nicht, wie meine E-Mail dahin gekommen sein soll, weil das unten Produkt, wo auf der englischen Seite...
Du bist doch Webmaster, oder? Sagst du? Du bist doch Webmaster.
Ich bin Webmaster, ja.
Und steht deine E-Mail-Adresse in irgendeiner deiner Webseiten?
Ähm, nee, nicht wahr. Ich bin zwar Webmaster von der Schulseite, aber die E-Mail-Adresse gehört halt der Schule.
Und die wird auch nicht angeschrieben?
Das weiß ich nicht. Darum kümmere ich mich seltener. Das macht halt noch niemand separat.
Achso, ist gar nicht deine, okay.
Nee, das ist nicht meine.
Aber schau mal, da gibt es jetzt irgendwie so eine Option, alle Header anzuzeigen oder alle Köpfe. Ich weiß nicht, wie das bei Audios heißt.
Die Empfänger.
Da nenne ich nicht die Empfänger, sondern es gibt irgendwo eine Option oder die Nachricht im Volltext anzuzeigen.
Ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht, was du von mir möchtest.
Na pass auf, du hast ja ein Fenster und dieses Fenster beinhaltet eine E-Mail, die an dich gesendet wurde, richtig?
Ja, auf die E-Mail habe ich doppelt geklickt.
Genau, jetzt drück mal die rechte Maustaste.
Und jetzt die rechte Maustaste, ja.
Vielleicht gibt es da eine Option, den ganzen Quelltext anzuzeigen oder irgendwie sowas?
Und oben im Menü gibt es doch sicherlich...
Ich wette, Kollegen, das ist wieder runtergebrochen und heißt so dumm wie mehr Informationen oder alle Informationen abzuzeigen.
Auf jeden Fall haben wir bewiesen, dass wir mit Outlook Express nicht umgehen können. Du wirst es finden, es ist wirklich in den meisten Programmen drin.
Auf jeden Fall, diese Header...
Diese Header können dir behilflich sein, weil eben bestimmte E-Mails, die man empfängt, eben auch bestimmte Inhalte in diesen Header haben.
Alle Kopfzeilen, ist das so was? Alle Kopfzeilen, oh Gott.
Alle Kopfzeilen, ja, Moment, ich muss mich mal anschalten. Jo, hat sich nicht viel geändert.
Alle Kopfzeilen fliegen hoch.
Ist das jetzt eine normale Mail oder eine Spam-Mail, die du bekommen, die du jetzt aufgemacht hast?
Ich nehm da eine Spam-Mail, weil if your home is serviced by a SEPIAC system, you will be able to... Weiß ich was, ja.
Das ist definitiv Spam. Das ist definitiv Spam.
Ja, es ist mein eigenes, nicht das beste, wie ihr merkt.
Aber es klingt wie Spam.
Es ist trotzdem Spam.
Ja, und ich meine, hier oben sehen auch lauter E-Mail-Adressen, die ich jetzt aus Datenschutzmeldungen nicht vorlese. Die wurden nämlich, wie für ein Blöd, über dieses CC gemacht von diesem Anbieter. Und ich habe auch festgestellt, dass ich von diesem Anbieter, nachdem ich die einmal storniert habe, die E-Mail, jetzt innerhalb von ein paar Wochen, glaube ich, zehn Stück von dem bekommen habe. Und das ist doch ziemlich heftig war. Und ich natürlich jetzt nicht weiß, was ich machen soll. Ich will nicht immer vierzehn von dem haben.
Also noch mal zu den Kopfzeilen oben. Da steht irgendwas mit Received oder Received by.
Moment, nochmal.
Irgendwas mit Received oder Received by. Received Doppelpunkt.
Hier steht von Datum an CC und betreff.
Das sind nicht alle Kopfzeilen.
Ich würde mal sagen, wir machen das folgendermaßen. Der Olaf kann ja noch ein bisschen basteln. Wir haben ja noch zwei Stunden Zeit, Olaf. Und wir gucken einfach mal, dass vielleicht jemand anruft, der seine Kopfzeilen oder wie auch immer das genannt sein mag. Der Header, der den Header schon geöffnet hat und einfach mal vorlesen kann, was da drin steht. Olaf, dank dir erst mal bis zu dem Punkt. Kannst du noch ein bisschen weiter üben, okay? Am Telefon ist nämlich noch der Jan. Jan? Jan sucht wahrscheinlich fieberhaft nach seinem Header, aber das ist ja auch okay. Hallo Friedl.
Lange gewartet.
Mit dem Outlook kann ich euch jetzt auch nicht weiterhelfen, weil Outlook ist ja mein Gott, Gott der Wahre, da muss man ja nicht unbedingt installieren. Kopfzeilen, ich suche gerade eine. Ich hab gerade Eudora offen und da sieht man die Kopfzeilen, leider Gottes auch nicht mehr wirklich.
Doch, und zwar gibt es da so ein Feld, da steht irgendwas mit bla. Ja, wenn du die Mail aufmachst, dann gibt es dann so ein kleines Icon, da steht bla.
Da steht wirklich bla.
Ach, guck an, da haben wir doch was. Oh ja, da haben wir wieder alle offen. Also zahlreiche X-Flags und Xe-Groove-Return, X-Sender und weiß ich nicht alles möglich mit X. Da könnt ihr eigentlich mal erklären, was diese X-Teile bedeuten.
X sind nicht standardisierte Header, die man sich selber ausdenken kann. Und weil sie eben nicht standardisiert sind, schreibt man X davor.
Ach so, ist das.
So was wie X-MS-Mail-Priority z.B. wo Windows-Mailsysteme ihr eigenes Prioritäten-System drin haben.
Dann haben wir halt noch viele Deliver-To und To, Mailing-List und et cetera.
Letzteres ist zum Beispiel ganz interessant. Wenn man auf einer Mailing-Liste eingetragen ist, dann weisen die Mails, die man über diese Mailing-Liste bekommt, nicht selten Header auf, an dem man relativ gut erkennen kann, dass sie von dieser Mailing-Liste sind. Das ist eine gute Methode, um mit Filtern Mails, die man eben von Mailing-Listen bekommen hat, auch ziemlich zielgerichtet in einen bestimmten Ort reinzutun.
Zum Thema Filter habe ich eine Frage. Ihr sagte vorhin mal davon, dass Filter irgendwie auch den Traffic, den Web-Traffic begrenzen würden. Das hat aber eigentlich nur eine Auswirkung auf das Internet, weil der einzige Traffic, der reduziert wird, ist der vom Mailserver zu mir nach Hause. Der vom Mailserver zu Mailserver, wenn die vom Sender kommen, der bleibt doch derselbe. Also wenn ich bei meinem locales Outlook hier oder Eudora so trimme, dass es mir die Dinger gar nicht zieht oder sofort löscht, dann liegen die trotzdem auf dem Server bzw. werden dann da gelöscht.
Aber für dich ist es schon mal ein ganz großer Unterschied, ob du den Spam gleich auf dem Server löscht oder erst runterlädst nach Hause. Weil es gibt auch noch Leute, die bezahlen für ihre Internetleitung nach Minuten oder Sekunden. Und mittlerweile bei ESDN ist das nicht mehr so dramatisch oder DSL, aber früher noch zu Modem-Zeiten. Also es gibt auch noch Leute, die Modems benutzen. Das ist dann schon ziemlich ärgerlich, wenn du einfach meinetwegen eine Gebühren-Einheit mehr hast oder so, nur weil da irgendwie 10 Spam-Mails gekommen sind. Insofern ist das schon dein Geld.
Na ja, okay, von dem Standpunkt aus stimmt das schon. Ich hab noch eine andere Frage, das zieh mir vorhin ein. Vor Jahren noch ging nicht nur der Begriff Spam durch die, hat man so gehört, sondern auch UCE. U-C-E, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Was bedeutet das eigentlich?
Das bedeutet unsolicited commercial email, also unverlangte kommerzielle Elektropost.
Und zweite Frage. Ich arbeite in einer kleinen Webdesign-Schmiede und wir haben zahlreiche Kunden, die häufiger mit Spam bombardiert werden. Jetzt hatten wir neulich einen so, der hat irgendwie so einen Form-Mail-Bug ausgenutzt und hat zigtausend E-Mails geschickt. Und da wollte ich fragen, inwiefern ist das überhaupt sinnvoll, sowas rechtlich zu verfolgen? Also ich meine, dass man einen Anwalt beschäftigen kann und dem viel Geld in den Rachen schmeißen kann, ist klar. Aber in welcher Hinsicht hat das wirklich einen Sinn?
Also gute Karten hast du schon mal, wenn du ein Gewerbetreibender bist und du bekommst Spam von einem Konkurrenten oder möglichen Konkurrenten. So, dann hast du da schon mal ganz gute Chancen, weil es ist dann halt ein lauterer Wettbewerb. Und in dem Moment hast du als Direktbetroffener eine Möglichkeit auch da zumindest auf Unterlassung zu klagen.
Na gut, aber von der Unterlassung habe ich erst mal noch nichts, wenn der mich vom Bombardier hat mit 100.000 E-Mails am am Tag und meinen Server lang gelegt hat etc.
Na ja, das ist dann schon wieder eine Dimension, wo du denn wirklich überlegen solltest. Aber nicht nur wegen Spam, sondern auch wenn es jetzt kein Spam gewesen wäre. Wenn es mit Absicht war, wenn es böse Absicht war.
Cyberwar.
Cyberwar, oh Gott der Gott.
Ja, nee ansonsten hab ich vorhin angerufen wegen irgendwas anderem. Das habt ihr aber glaube ich schon erledigt. Richtig, was kann man wirklich dagegen tun, dass jemand über solche Sachen wie direkt auf den Server per PHP E-Mails verschickt, wirklich den kompletten Heller verändern kann? Das habe ich noch nicht mal aus Spaßes halber versucht. Und du kannst wirklich alles ändern.
Ja, das hat ja die Bild-Zeitung mittlerweile auch bemerkt.
Das ist ein Grundfeature von E-Mails. Wenn man sich anschaut, wie das Internet E-Mailsystem funktioniert, stellt man schnell fest, alles was irgendwie losgeschickt wird, wird meist auch komplett an der ersten los-sendenden Stelle geschrieben. Eine E-Mail erfährt zwar einige Behandlungen, während sie irgendwie weitergereicht wird, aber es wird in der Regel nur etwas hinzugefügt. Das heißt, du kannst mit deinem Mailer im Prinzip alles Mögliche los schicken. Das heißt, du kannst irgendeine E-Mail-Adresse als Absender angeben, die es überhaupt nicht gibt zum Beispiel. Die Frage ist eben immer nur, nimmt dir dein weiterleitender Mailserver diese Mail auch ab. Schauen sie sich das schon an und führen so bestimmte Plausibilitätskontrollen durch heutzutage und öffnen sich nicht unbedingt jedem. Und da sind auch in den letzten Jahren diverse Maßnahmen ergriffen worden, um das einzudämmen, was teilweise zu anderen technischen Problemen geführt hat, weil manche Systemadministratoren ziemlich wahnwitzige Paranoia fahren und irgendwie alles abschalten, was auch nur im entferntesten unter Umständen vielleicht mal Spam ist. Und das führt dann dazu, dass man viele wirklich wichtige Dinge auf einmal nicht mehr tun kann. Aber generell kannst du erstmal alles einstellen. Das heißt, das ist das, wogegen man sich wehren muss und das ist technisch relativ schwierig.
Also wie macht ihr das eigentlich für euch? Weiß ich nicht, ein Privatakonto oder so? Filtert ihr da wirklich die Dinge und löscht die nach bestimmten Stichworten? Weil, wenn mir irgendwer mal irgendwas schreibt und da zufällig das Wort Dollar reinschreibt oder Money Free oder was weiß ich, was man da so hat, dann landet die gleich im Nirvana oder guckt ihr die trotzdem noch irgendwie durch, überfliegt die oder wie macht ihr das?
Verloren geht nichts wirklich Wichtiges.
Da kann man ja verschiedene Strategien wählen. Zum ersten kannst du gucken, wer der einlieferende Mailserver ist, also von wem diese Post tatsächlich bei dir eintrifft, ob es diesen Server gibt, ob es diesen Hostnamen gibt, mit dem er sich meldet. Also gewisse technische Grundlagen verifizieren. Der Punkt ist, es bringt dir noch nichts, denn das ist nicht zwangsläufig dann Spam. In der nächsten Ebene kannst du zuerst alles wegfiltern, was an eine dir bekannte Adresse geht, was von einer dir bekannten Adresse kommt. Das heißt, du kannst die Post deines Freundes Peter in die Mailbox Peter sortieren und kannst all die Post an deine Mailadresse, die du der Deutsche Bahn AG gegeben hast, verwenden, um den Spam, den die Deutsche Bahn schickt, verlangt, in einen Ordner wegzusortieren. Und dann bleibt relativ wenig übrig und der Großteil davon ist tatsächlich Spam. Das ist aber auch natürlich wieder kein Exklusivgrund, um die Mail dann wegzuwerfen. Wenn du aber mehrere dieser Ebenen machst, kannst du relativ gut korrelieren, wenn alles falsch ist. Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es eine nicht an dich gerichtete Mail ist, ist relativ hoch und du kannst in die Tonne treten. Ich für meinen Teil hebe mir das trotzdem auf, weil Plattenplatz heutzutage nichts mehr kostet und mein Mailfolder ein Zwanzigstel meiner Platte in Anspruch nimmt insofern.
Nee, das lesen wir hier im Radio vor.
Oder wenn man mal einen lustigen Abend haben möchte. Also die Strategien sind schon... Das erste, was du genannt hast, Andreas, erfordert natürlich schon auch einen gewissen hohen technischen Aufwand. So was wie automatisch Absende, Hosts, dynamisch überprüfen, welchen Stand sie denn so gerade haben im Internet. Das ist halt schon dann was eben für einen gehobenen Systemadministrator. Mit dem normalen E-Mails-Software, mit den Filtertechnologien muss man eher halt so rangehen. Erstmal alles irgendwo hin an definierte Orte filtern, was irgendwie klar erkennbar ist. Da hilft das natürlich auch, wenn die Systemadministratoren von den Mailing-Listen, auf denen man ist, ihre Listen auch im Griff haben, dass da zum Beispiel schon mal kein Spam drauf landet, einerseits. Auf der anderen Seite, dass die auch die Mails, die von dieser Mailing-Liste kommen, entsprechend leicht erkennbar machen, dass sie von dieser Mailing-Liste kommen. Da sind manche besser, manche schlechter. Und die andere Strategie finde ich auch gut, wenn du bestimmte E-Mail-Adressen sowieso mehr Vertrauen schickst oder dass die Leute sind, die dir generell was schicken, dass du die botanmalst oder keine Ahnung. Man muss ja nicht gleich wegschmeißen, man kann sie dann auch irgendwie weglegen und irgendwann vielleicht mal ein paar Skripte rüberjagen, die dann analysieren, wo es jetzt eigentlich hergekommen ist, ob die ganze Spam der letzten zehn Jahre in irgendeiner Form ein erkennbares Überwachungsmuster abwirft.
Das Einzige, was mir so einfällt zum Thema Spam, habt ihr das zufällig auch? Der RS2-Gewinner-Club schickt irgendwie immer Real-Life-Spam, der schickt immer Post an Bekannter von mir und an mich selbst. Obwohl ich noch nie irgendwas mit RS2 zu tun habe. Das finde ich doch irgendwie sehr seltsam, dass sie sich einen Aufwand machen und immer wirklich Post verschicken mit echten Briefmarken drauf. Und nicht mal irgendwas gesammelt ist mit gestempelt, sondern richtige Briefmarken. Und die müssen da ein Heidengeld investieren.
Das nennt sich Direct-Marketing. Und da fällt halt Spam voll mit rein. Da sieht man auch, wie gut das miteinander verzahnt ist. Das ist für die nur ein weiteres Outlet. Ihre Methoden, die Massen zu attackieren und ihnen irgendwie auf ihre Dummheit zu setzen.
Friedl, dank dir. Alles klar. Das wird ja ganz schön speziell. Das ist der Chaosradio Blue Moon zum Thema heute Spam im Studio, die Kollegen Frank, Andreas, Tim und meine Wenigkeit Malotki und die Frage, ob denn der gesunde Menschenverstand heute überhaupt nicht mehr zählt. Ich meine, es gibt immer solche Probleme. Wenn ich jetzt einen Brief schreibe an einen Freund, dann schreibe ich auch nicht vorne drauf, Antragsbombe Präsidenten töten, sodass die Post sich direkt sagt, okay, das Ding kommt jetzt schon mal in die Kammer und dass ich diesen Brief nicht kriege. Ich kann doch nun mit meinen Freunden sprechen und denen sagen, bitte benutzt einfach keine Idioten-E-Mail-Adressen, oder? Also so dieser klassische Ich spreche mit dir Kontakt, der solche Sachen verhindert?
Du meinst so Benutzererziehung?
Ja, sowas.
Na ja, man kann schon eine ganze Menge Ratschläge geben, aber machen wir uns nichts vor. Das ganze Internet-Mail-System ist hochgradig komplex, sondern es sind viele Leute, die sich jeden Tag was Neues einfallen lassen. Und es ist schon nicht grundsätzlich so, dass man immer eine Chance hat. Man hat natürlich eine, und es ist immer die gleiche Antwort, wenn es um Computer geht, umso mehr Zeit man sich damit nimmt, es zu verstehen, wie es funktioniert, umso bessere Ergebnisse hat man. Und das gilt sicherlich auch hier bei Mail. Es lohnt auf jeden Fall, wenn man irgendwie wirklich auf E-Mails setzt, sich auch mal etwas eingehender mit der Methodik auseinanderzusetzen. Ich denke, dass viele Firmen das heute auf keinen Fall tun. Die kriegen ja irgendwie ihre Windows-2000-Box oder jetzt diese neue Bonbon-Variante davon. Und dann ist es da drauf und dann haben sie irgendwie ihr Microsoft-Setup und klicke die Klicke, alles default, und dann funktioniert das schon. Sieh mal, da kommt doch schon die erste E-Mail, unser toller Server läuft. Dann sind sie glücklich und verkaufen wieder, was weiß ich, Eisenbahnspielzeug oder so, keine Ahnung. Und dann geht es halt irgendwann los mit der Katastrophe. Einerseits kriegen sie halt irgendwie Mail, die sie nicht verstehen, auf die sie vielleicht auch noch falsche, keine Ahnung, weißte so. Der Konkurrent schickt dann einfach mal so eine Mail rein. Schick mir doch mal kurz die Unterlagen von gestern noch mal per Anhang. Und ohne dass groß drüber nachgedacht wird, von wem denn das nun wirklich ist, gehen dann erst mal die Daten raus. Dann diese Virenproblematik, die auch sehr eng ist, verzahnt ist mit diesem ganzen Spam. Aber ja, auch diese ganzen Funktionalitäten, die diese Sicherheitslöcher so aufmachen, so wie Browser starten, HTML anzeigen, JavaScript aktivieren, andere Scriptsprachen, dieses Mailprogramms aktivieren, was dann auf einmal anfängt, irgendwelche Dinge zu tun, wie selber Mails zu verschicken, ganze Probleme mit dem E-Mail-Virus, I love you und so, die dann irgendwie mal eben tausende Mail-Server in großen Firmen platt gemacht haben. All das ist auch immer eine Frage des Verständnisses, und wie ernsthaft man sich damit beschäftigt. Und wenn man es nicht versteht, dann soll man auch bitte sein Business nicht drauf stützen.
So eine klassische Frage, die ich mir selber auch noch nicht beantworten konnte, ist es eigentlich gefährlich? Das finde ich nämlich spannend bei einem E-Mail-Programm. Die sind ja alle so gestrickt, dass die mittlerweile alle 15.000 Fenster schon offen haben. Das heißt, wenn du deine Mail bekommst, und da ist oben halt die Mail, die die gemeine Mail ist, und aus Versehen dein Balken da drauf steht, öffnet die sich ja unten sofort in diesem Vorschaufenster. Ist das relevant? Ist es schon dann, wenn da ein Virus drin ist, schon geöffnet oder noch nicht?
Ja, also es gibt dieses Active Scripting bei Microsoft und da kann eine Mail, also das kann ein HTML-Code, also einer formatierten Bridge-Mail, sogenannten, kann es enthalten sein. Und dann im ungünstigen Fall auch schon ein Anzeigen geöffnet werden. Zumal die Möglichkeit ja auch besteht, wenn noch eine Internetverbindung besteht, wenn ich die Mail aufmache, dass über eingebettete Sachen, im HTML-Code, die gar nicht in der Mail selbst drin sind, sondern woanders auf dem Server sind, da wird dann durch den Mail auch zugegriffen. Und dann kann da im Prinzip auch alles kommen.
Also Mails im Grunde gar nicht mehr aufmachen, nicht?
Das ist so ein bisschen wie früher mit den Disketten. Nein, du steckst deine dreckige Diskette nicht in meinen Computer, weil die war da draußen in der freien Welt und weiß der Geier.
Wobei, also es gibt bei Mails, ist ja nicht automatisch so, sondern das sind ja irgendwie nur bestimmte Programme, wo das dann so gemacht wird, weil Software wie Eudora oder TheBet, da wird so ein HTML-Code nicht ausgeführt. Also der wird vielleicht bestensfalls angezeigt oder vielleicht noch gefragt vorher, ob er angezeigt werden soll. Dann besteht die Möglichkeit gar nicht. Wenn da nichts ausgeführt wird, dann brauch ich mir auch keine Sorgen machen. Das ist dann harmlos.
Sind das solche Einstellungen, die man im Zweifelsfall auch bei Outlook, ich meine die meisten werden sich daran gewöhnt haben und nehmen dann doch nicht Abstand davon, ausgeschaltet werden können?
Nicht so richtig. Ein wichtiger Tipp ist auf jeden Fall, das Active Scripting auszuschalten. Ich weiß nicht, wie da die Active Scripting host oder so was heißt es. Und dann bin ich auf jeden Fall schon mal gegen diese bösen, kleinen Miniprogramme gefeiert. HTML-Code wird glaube ich immer angezeigt von Outlook. Da weiß nicht, vielleicht ist da draußen jemand, der weiß, wie das abzuschalten wird.
Und nicht gleich auf jedes Attachment klingen.
Hm, mein Attachment.
Also die Anhänge, die sind das größte Problem.
Happy Christmas.
Da kommen sie halt irgendwie alle an. Also ich hab's ja irgendwie auch schon mal erzählt, ich erinnere mich immer wieder gerne daran, es war vor einigen Jahren, wo so das erste Mal Fragen an uns herangetragen wurden, ob den Viren in E-Mails übertragen werden können, ob Leute ein Problem haben, wenn sie Mail öffnen, ob dann irgendwas Schlimmes passieren kann.
Und wir haben uns alle schlapp gelacht.
Und sie haben nur das schallendes Gelächter geerntet, weil wir uns halt dachten, so ein Blödsinn, wie soll denn bitteschön in einer E-Mail ein Virus sein? Wir haben halt einfach nicht mit der Dummheit der Programmierer gerechnet oder dieser Firmen oder ihrer Beabsichtigungen, dass sie ernsthaft so etwas einbauen würden, dass man in einer E-Mail Code platziert und den auch noch ausfildern lässt, noch ohne zu fragen. Also das war dermaßen fern jeglicher denkbaren Realität, dass wir das einfach nur als Scherz auffassen konnten. Und wie es immer so schön ist, die Realität holt einen dann schnell wieder ein und macht einem klar, dass alle doch viel dümmer sind, als man irgendwie es für möglich gehalten hat.
Einer, der eigentlich ganz schlau ist, aber auch eine Frage hat, ist der Andreas. Nee, Christian. Christian, hallo, Christian.
Ja, hallo.
Ich hab eigentlich keine Frage, aber... Doch nicht.
Ich bin Mehrarztministerator, deswegen wollte ich anrufen. Ja, großes Haus und eine kleine Firma. Genau was will ich nicht sagen.
Also ein in der freien Wirtschaft tätiges Unternehmen, was unter Umständen einen etwas bekannteren Namen hat.
Hoffen wir es mal. Das E-Mails-System macht ungefähr 5.000, 6.000 Mails pro Tag Umsatz. Da haben wir dann doch schon mehr mit Spam zu tun. Sonst andere in der Firma ist halt ein bisschen kleiner. Es gibt nicht so viele. Es gibt ein paar Möglichkeiten, Spam richtig zu verhindern. Aber es ist schwierig. Als wirksamste Methode hat sich erwiesen, es gibt so eine RBL, real-time Blacklist. Das heißt, das ist eine Liste, die von irgendwelchen Leuten gepflegt wird, die Mailer aufnehmen, die für Spam bekannt sind. Das heißt, wer als Spam-Versender richtig aufgefallen ist, also als offenes Relay, wird in dieser Liste geführt. Jedes Mal, wenn so ein Server connectet bei einem Mailsystem, wird eine DNS-Anfrage gemacht, ob dieser Server in dieser Blackliste drin ist. Wenn ja, dann wird er abgewiesen oder wird mit einem speziellen Flag versehen. Und dann geht es halt so weiter. Der Nachteil dabei ist, es gibt offene Input-Relays und offene Output-Relays. Input heißt, man kann mit irgendeiner Adresse reinschicken und die schicken das weiter. Oder beim Output-Relay ist es so, dass man nur eine Absendenadresse von der Domain kennen muss. Und dann mit bla bla bla unterstrich irgendeine Zahl add die lokale Domain dort, kann man das dahinschicken und der schickt das dann weiter ins Internet raus. Und der Nachteil bei dem System war, dass die Output-Listen, die sollte man auf Warning stellen, also dass die User nur gewarnt werden, weil das Problem ist, dass da diverse Peer-Online-Mailer drin sind und diverse Strato-Mailer und das macht die Sache etwas unsexy für die Leute. Ich hatte es einmal auf Reject gestellt und das war der Fehler. Und bei den Input-Listen, wo man mit irgendeiner Adresse reinschicken kann, und das geht raus, die werden komplett abgewiesen. Das heißt, die sind einfach nur bekannt dafür, dass sie nur noch Spam verschicken. Da sind die Japaner sehr gut vertreten.
Sie können, bevor wir jetzt zur nächsten Geschichte kommen, bei mir war ja vor zwei Minuten schon das weiße Rauschen am Start.
Genau, um es vielleicht etwas transparenter zu machen, worum es jetzt geht. Wir sind jetzt auf der eigentlichen Netz- und Mail-Weiterleitungsebene. Es ist natürlich schon seit Langem so, dass von den Administratoren gefordert wird, dass sie doch irgendwie dieses Problem in den Griff kriegen sollen. Das ist natürlich eben gleiche Problematik wie das Filtern beim End-User. Man muss halt gut wissen, was lehne ich jetzt ab und was ist eben tatsächlich einfach legale Mail. Oder digitime Mail, wie man das auch immer ausdrücken möchte. Und die Entscheidung ist halt nicht schwierig und das System, das er jetzt beschrieben hat, basiert im Wesentlichen darauf, dass man eben auch so eine Art Notwarnungssystem hat, wo eben, wenn irgendwo viel Spam rausgeht, dass man eben schaut, welcher Computer hat denn zuletzt diese Mail weiter gereicht.
Ja, also welcher Mailer connectet gerade zu dir und wenn der in so einer Liste drin ist, dann wird als Spam wenigstens markiert.
Sekunde mal, Jungs, ganz kurze Frage. Viele erfahren dieses Wort mit dieser Blackliste. Da hab ich ja aufgehorcht, das ist jetzt nur was, was für Leute interessant ist, die selber einen Server unterhalten.
Richtig?
Oder ist das sowas, wo ich ihnen ein kleines Programm holen kann, wo ich sage, ich greife als Privatuser auf diese Liste im Internet zu und nach den Kriterien wird gefiltert oder gibt es das nicht?
Sowas gibt es auch. Ich weiß nicht, ob das in den Mailern irgendwie einbaubar ist unter Windows. Für die Unix-Leute, da gibt es das auf jeden Fall. Das basiert darauf, dass der Serverbetreiber, also der Mail-Serverbetreiber, sprich mein Provider zum Beispiel, dann so eine Sache dann nicht weiterleitet, wenn es auf diesen Blacklist ist. Da gibt es übrigens auch eine Geschichte aus Amerika, dass eine Firma geklagt hat, aus einer Blacklist wieder rausgenommen zu werden. Und das musste irgendwie vor Gericht verhandelt werden und so. Das ist natürlich die Problematik dahinter. Das heißt, wenn ich einmal ein offenes Relay, also so ein Mail-Weiterleitungssender habe, der einfach alles annimmt und weiterleitet, dann kann ich unter Umständen ein Problem haben. Und dann habe ich halt irgendwelche Kunden, die sich beschweren, sagen, ich kann hier keine E-Mail verschicken, das kommt hier zurück, weil hier wird mir gesagt, dass ich böse bin und was ist los?
Dieser Maps-Betreiber, der da verklagt wurde, hat übrigens danach sein System aufs Bezahlen umgestellt.
Was hat er dafür geschrieben?
Da muss man quasi jetzt dafür bezahlen, dass man die Listen benutzen darf.
Wixi, V-I-X-I-E. Der hat auch Bind geschrieben und also den DNS-Dienst des Internets.
Das kam mir noch gleich bekannt vor.
Ein weiteres Problem aber von diesen Listen ist, dass offensichtlich ziemlich viele Spam-Versender jetzt auf den Trichter gekommen sind. Wir nehmen einfach das Backup-MX, also eine Mail-Server-Kette, sollte so aufgebaut sein, dass man hat einen Haupt-Mail-Server, der als erstes versucht wird, den man zuerst anspricht. Wenn der nicht da ist, nimmt man den zweiten und das ist so ein Fallback-System, also dass man immer einen Schritt zurückgeht und seine Mail erstmal los ist. Und die Server-Server...
Kein Anschluss mit diesem Gehirn.
Ja, also kann irgendjemand was verständlicher klären?
Jungs, die Fallback-Falle bitte, was ist die Fallback-Falle?
Was dieser Anrufer ziemlich gut klar macht, ist, dass man ein sehr tiefes technisches Verständnis des Internet aufbringen muss, um so etwas einfaches wie eine unverlangte Mail irgendwie zuverlässig herauszufiltern, ohne anderen größeren Schaden anzurichten. Das ist einfach richtig ärgerlich. Deswegen ist es eben auch so ärgerlich, dass die Politik nicht bereit war, gleich von vornherein mal zu sagen, erst mal nicht, und über alles andere können wir ja reden. Aber es war halt eher ein, ja, erst mal schon, und dann reden wir nochmal. Das bringt natürlich genau überhaupt nichts, aber das ist auch weltweit so. Allein jetzt mit nationalen oder auch europäischen Regelungen wäre auch nicht so viel zu verhindern gewesen. Aber das wäre schon erträglicher. Oder? Das ist sicherlich ähnlich. Dein Tag, wie viel, bist du nur Mailadministrator? Und wie sehr, meinst du, beschäftigt dich insbesondere diese Spam-Problematik im Vergleich zu anderen Problemen, die du bei Mail hast?
Naja, also muss ich mindestens die Waage halten am Tag. Spam nimmt mittlerweile nicht mehr so viel ein, weil bei manchen Sachen, da kann man sich nicht mehr darum kümmern. Also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel 200 Mails in der Que stehen und warten darauf ausgeliefert zu werden, und man sieht, dass es alles von einem Absender kommt und alles hat so ein komisches Subject wie Tralali, Tralala, you want cash? Dann kann man schon noch schnell reagieren. Dass man den jetzt einfach abblockt. Aber ansonsten, naja, viel kann man da nicht mehr machen.
Und wie viel Prozent würdest du sagen ist das so deiner Arbeit?
Schwer zu sagen, also 20 Prozent vielleicht.
Hast du denn schon mal eine Mail an abuse at deine Adresse bekommen? Eine Mail an abuse.
At deine Domain?
Hast du die eingerichtet? Aber hast du noch keine bekommen? Diese Mail-Adresse ist die Mail-Adresse, wo so eine, ja, so eine...
Die man eingerichtet haben sollte.
Und damit so eine Vorfälle gemeldet werden können. Das heißt, ich kann diese Liste von diesen Headern durchgehen, von den Received-Adressen und nehme den untersten in der Liste und schreibe da eine abuse at diese Adresse und sag, dass ich hier Spam gekriegt hab und es kam von dir und mach da was gegen. Jetzt hat es hier so viel gerastelt und...
Du hast recht, Frank. Man muss es einrichten. Du hast es eingerichtet und dir ist noch nie was passiert. Bei dir wurde noch nicht abuse oder kann es auf die Idee gekommen, sich zu beschweren?
Ja, man empfängt nur haufenweise Spam. Ansonsten, dass du rausgegangen hast, war nüsst.
Prima.
Glück gehabt. Was für Betriebssysteme haben deine Mail Server?
Alle Linux.
Ist klar.
Welcher Mailer?
Okay, welcher Mailer?
Ich nicke jetzt auch mal wissend wie alle im Studio, nur das Gute. Und Christian, mach's gut, wenn man jetzt Nachricht.
Wenn Fritz in Frankfurt, oder? Dann 101, 5.
23 Uhr 31. Mit dem Wetter, das sich von derlei technischem Wissen natürlich nicht beeindrucken hat, lassen nachts vorübergehend gering bewölkt und es wird sich abkühlen auf 3 bis 0 Grad. Morgen anfangs gebietsweise Regen oder Schneeregen, später wieder Schauer bei 6 bis 9 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Boehner.
Die Unions Bundestagsfraktion hat sich mit großer Mehrheit gegen den Kompromissvorschlag der rot-grünen Bundesregierung zum Zuwanderungsgesetz ausgesprochen. Auf einer Sondersitzung gab es am Abend allerdings drei Gegenstimmen. Der Innenausschuss des Bundestages hatte den Entwurf vor dem Zuwanderungsgesetz zuvor gebilligt. Der frühere brandenburgische Bauminister Wolf ist zu 5 Jahren Haft verurteilt worden. Das Potsdamer Landgericht sah es als erwiesen an, dass Wolf seine Ehefrau ermorden lassen wollte. Saudi-Arabien hat die Europäische Union um Unterstützung für seinen Nahost-Friedensplan gebeten. Kronprinz Abdullah informierte heute in Chida den außenpolitischen EU-Beauftragten Solana über Einzelheiten des Vorschlags. In der Affäre um die Bankgesellschaft Berlin sind die ehemaligen AUBIS-Geschäftsführer Neuling und Wienholdt erneut festgenommen worden. Beide wurden am Nachmittag dem Haftrichter vorgeführt. Es bestehe Fluchtgefahr, hieß es. Nach mehr als 50 Jahren geht die Ära der D-Mark morgen zu Ende. Gezahlt werden kann nach dem 28. Februar nur noch mit dem Euro. Auch in den meisten anderen Euro-Staaten verlieren die alten Münzen und Scheine ihre Gültigkeit. Und zum Sportfußball in der Champions League gewann Arsenal London gegen Bayern Leverkusen 4 zu 1. In der deutschen Eissaukeliga verloren die Eisbären Berlin in München 3 zu 4 nach Penalty-Schießen. Und es liegen keine aktuellen Meldungen zum Verkehr vor, außer, dass hier in diesem Studio ein reger Verkehr wieder herrscht, weil die Jungs wieder reinkommen.
Mann, wär das toll, wenn Wünsche wahr würden.
Ja, wenn endlich mal genau...
Deine persönlichen Lieblingssongs laufen würden.
Genau, aber...
Aber ansteigen willst du dich nicht dafür.
Nö.
Na ja, dann ruf doch einfach an. 0331 70 97 130.
Openbox, die Sendung, bei der garantiert nichts passiert. Außer, dass eure Wünsche erfüllt werden. Eine Stunde Lieblingssongs. Von Montag bis Freitag immer ab 19 Uhr.
Kann ich da auch jemand grüßen?
Klar, aber immer schön 0331 70 97 130 anrufen. Openbox, die fast vollautomatische Wunscherfüllungs-Show. Und überhaupt im Radio.
Ja, die startstreitende Musik des Abends kommt aus Wien von einer Band namens Monomania. Hier nochmal ein Dank an die Kollegen vom ORF.
Und ihr habt den Chaosradio Blue Moon. Das war so eine kleine Ergänzung, die man vielleicht noch machen könnte. Weil es heute Abend um ein grundsätzlich sehr interessantes Thema geht, was uns augenscheinlich auch alle wirklich betrifft. Denn wir haben ja hier einen Blick darin, wie viele Leute nun wirklich anrufen. Und es rufen ne Menge Leute an. Und dann 0373-979110. Aufgrund der Tatsache, dass alle irgendwie Spam bekommen. Und ihr könnt das auch weiter tun unter eben gesagter Nummer. Wollen wir denn sozusagen eine neue Etappe in Sachen thematischer Aufarbeitung gehen, Kollegen?
Man nicht so kompliziertes Zeug reden.
Das passiert mir immer.
Man versteht ja fast nicht.
Und das passiert mir hauptsächlich deswegen, weil ich euren Clubmate trinke, den ich immer wieder gerne erwähnen will.
Willst du eine neue?
Mhm, gerne.
Kommt sofort.
Soweit die immer wieder nötige...
Wir haben ja genug Treibstoff dabei...
.Thematisierung des...
Ja, noch mal eine von den Webcam-Stellen...
.Nahrungsangebotes.
Keine Ahnung, ob die Webcam funktioniert.
Sie funktioniert.
Aber falls ihr schon immer wissen wolltet, was man so zu trinken hat, wenn man irgendwie gut draufkommen möchte, dann...
Ja, und zwar fand ich jetzt das Thema Spam und der Outlook und allen anderen Sachen ziemlich interessant, aber irgendwie wurde so das Thema Spam in Insta-Messages ein bisschen als Weisenkind bis jetzt behandelt.
Na, dann gib uns doch mal die Richtung vor.
Na, eigentlich wollte ich dir ja nur mal kurz ansprechen. Ich wollte eigentlich gar nicht so viel dazu sagen. Ich wollte einfach sagen, dass es da eben dasselbe Problem gibt mit Messages oder mit Wilden Earth, die mir irgendwer hier zuschickt. Also ich sag mal, wenn man eben eine Standleitung hat, dann hat man das eben dauerhaft on und naja, Problem, Problem. Und unter ICQ gibt es irgendwie noch nicht so eine Art Filter. Also ich kann die Leute auf eine Ignore-Liste setzen. Ist ja nicht so ein Problem. Aber die besorgen sich jedes Mal wieder einen neuen Account. Das sieht man an den Nummern. Die sind ja fast schon fortlaufend. Und ja, jetzt sind wir schon bei irgendwo 15, 11 am Anfang angekommen. Also das wird dann morgen wahrscheinlich schon die 15, 12 sein und so weiter und so fort. Und das finde ich irgendwie, da ist man noch wesentlich hilfloser, weil da gibt es die Filter-Eschichte nicht so.
Wie funktioniert das mit diesen Messen? Ich benutze sowas irgendwie nicht. Da gibt es dann so eine, also wie kommen die denn an die Adressen von den Teilnehmern?
Ja, man kann auf sogenannten White Pages, kann man eben sich Leute nach bestimmten Kriterien raussuchen, nehme ich mal an, dass diese so machen, weil sie schicken irgendwie nur, naja, ok, das Thema ist irgendwie immer dieselbe von wegen, naja, ok, dieselbe wie in den Spam-E-Mails, also hier XXX hier und da. Und ich schütze mal, die werden einfach nach männlichen Jugendlichen zwischen, was weiß ich, 18 und 30 suchen und einfach an die dann eben eine Nachricht rausschicken, ja, hallo, hier ist so und so und ich bin unter da und da zu sehen mit meinem Freund, blablabla, irgendwie so in die Richtung.
Welche Instant-Messaging-Systeme benutzt du?
Eigentlich schon ewig ICQ, ich hab zwischendurch mal ein bisschen Oligo und MSN probiert, aber die sind alle nervig. Also MSN ist ja wirklich unter XP ein Traum, weil den kriegt man ja im Guten eigentlich gar nicht raus. Mit ein paar Tricks schon, aber ich sag mal, das war schon ein Ding an sich, aber ich bin mit ICQ eigentlich am, fahr ich eigentlich am besten, weil ich hab die meisten von meinen Leuten.
Und bei ICQ ist es auf jeden Fall ein Problem. Also wir haben nicht so viel Instant-Messaging, weil wir schon E-Mails irgendwie so schnell schicken und lesen, dass es Instant-Messaging gleicht. Aber das ist natürlich auf jeden Fall genauso ein Problem. Wie Telefonanrufe im Prinzip.
Ja, ungefähr. Ich hab jetzt mal seitdem die Sendung löst, hab ich jetzt mal bei meinen ICQ nicht angefasst. Und ich hab jetzt schon neun Earths wieder, die hier blinken und mir auf irgendwelche tollen Seiten zeigen wollen, die eigentlich überhaupt keiner sehen will. Nee, die drücke ich immer gleich weg. Da geh ich eigentlich einfach so rauf und dann auf Delete. Weil das Problem ist, die kann man nicht auf eine Ignore-Liste setzen. Also Nachrichten, die aufpoppen, kann man abstellen, sag ich mal, für jeden Tag.
Messenger an der Poppen Nachrichten? Also ist das denn ein extra Fenster, oder wie funktioniert das?
Ja, ich sag mal bei jedem neuen User. Ich mein, man kann das bei den Einstellungen so einstellen, dass es nicht aufpoppt. Aber wenn meine Leute mich anschreiben und ich krieg sie grad nicht mit, weil ich grad, was weiß ich, den Sound nicht an hab oder so, dann würd ich das verpassen. Also dass sie sich einfach zwischenpoppen.
Sag mal, hast du das auch? Weil das kenn ich von ICQ, glaub ich sogar, dass man bestimmte, dass man seine Adresse nicht veröffentlichen kann, blabla. Und dann gibt's aber so Messages, die technischer Kategorie sind, die aber trotzdem von fremden Leuten losgeschickt werden und dann aufpoppen und an allem vorbeikommen.
Einen Problem hatt ich noch nicht. Also wenn ich wirklich meinen Ruh haben will, dann stell ich den entweder auf Away oder auf Invisible oder Do Not Disturb und dann bleiben die Nachrichten im Hintergrund eigentlich. Also ich hab noch nicht gehabt, dass ein Nachricht sich wirklich beim, was weiß ich, einfach beim Videokucken dazwischengeknallt hat.
Also unser Problem ist, dass wir irgendwie EM-Systeme kaum benutzen, von daher auch hier auch keine qualifizierte Aussage machen können. Aber vielleicht ruft ja noch jemand an, der sich mit EM-Spam-Problematik auskennt. Dir können wir jetzt auf jeden Fall erstmal nicht groß weiterhelfen.
Aber zum Thema Spam in Outlook nochmal. Also da gibt's eigentlich im neuen Outlook von XP gibt's da die Option Junk-E-Mails und da kann man eigentlich auch direkt die Benutzer, von denen man die kriegt. Also wenn man natürlich diese Hotmail-Accounts hat mit den vielen Nummern hinterhand, ist natürlich klar. Aber ich sag mal Sachen, wo man öfter was von kriegt, die kann man auf eine Liste setzen und die werden entweder markiert oder gleich rausgeschmissen.
Ist dir schon mal passiert, dass du Spam von der gleichen Adresse bekommen hast?
Äh ja, diese, diese...
Frank Steffel Powerpoint-Handcuff.
Wie es jetzt nicht mehr, und wo das ja auch noch drum hängt, irgendwie von Redlight, irgendwie so. Die lassen sich ja auch irgendwie nicht mal abzumähen. Also da ist extra so ein Unsubscribed-Link unten drunter und naja, wenn man da drauf drückt, hat man vielleicht wieder drei neue da oder die sagen ja, wir kennen die richtig.
Ist so, ne?
Naja, also die wollen sich gar nicht loswerden lassen.
Wenn wir schon mal beim Thema andere Plattformen sind, Interestant Message, die ist ja wohl auch inzwischen von Spam betroffen, eine völlig neue Dimension, die uns allen Freude bereitet, Spam aufs Mobilfunktelefon, SMS mit Werbung und...
Dieses Hotel wurde gerade für sie gebucht. Das hatte ich schon mal auf dem Handy, hab ich gedacht, was hab ich denn vergessen? Hatte ich sogar schon mal, zweimal. Zweimal schon.
Fax-Spam ist auch sehr wichtig.
Den meisten SMS-Spam kriege ich noch von Freunden über SMS-Verteiler-Systeme im Web, wo man sich seine eigenen SMS-Verteiler pflegen kann. Das ist natürlich auch eine tolle Sache, um irgendwie Adressen, Telefonnummern und Zusammenhänge zwischen Telefonnummern irgendwie mitzudrücken. Und Handys sind einfach mal noch am allerschlechtesten gerüstet. Also wenn man sich anschaut, was man jetzt in so was wie Eudora, welche komplexe Funktionalität man im Prinzip benötigt, um überhaupt der Sache herzuwerden, das gleiche Drama wird bei SMS irgendwann auch losgehen, da tippert man sich irgendwie wund. Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Dann wird Microsoft sich überlegen, dass es doch toll wäre ein Programm anzubieten, wo man eigentlich nur per Default einstellen muss, dass man sowas nicht bekommt. Dann holen sich das alle, da sind aber zwei Bugs drin, die man wunderbar ausnutzen kann.
Demnächst drohen uns tatsächlich Microsoft-Handys irgendwie. Microsoft ist kräftig davor, das zu machen. Natürlich werden sie da irgendwie ihre Outlook-Synchronisation haben und lalala. Und dann hat man das ganze Drama mit sich selbst ausführenden Code und so weiter auch noch in seinem Telefon.
Dann wird man wahrscheinlich im Flieger immer den Piloten bitten, müssen den Flieger nicht anzuschalten, weil dann das Handy abstürzt, sozusagen. Aber ich bin ja stolz in froh.
Oder auch andere Sachen, wo wir uns irgendwie noch lange Zeit gedacht haben, das kommt nicht. Zum Beispiel gibt es auch diesen Mythos, es gäbe Mobiltelefone, die sich einfach selber einschalten und irgendwie ein Gespräch übertragen, ohne dass irgendwas aus dem Lautsprecher kommt, ohne dass wir irgendwas anzeigen würden, sie tun es einfach. Bisher gibt es dafür noch keinen Beleg. Aber in dem Moment, wo irgendwie Java in die Handys kommt und du bist gerade so dabei und andere Funktionalitäten, vor allem wenn Microsoft dann irgendwie wieder mit ihrem Kram kommt, wo sie ja immer so viele Features drin haben, dann kann man echt für nichts mehr garantieren. Also derzeit ist es eher noch ein Gerücht und in drei Jahren sitzen wir wahrscheinlich hier im Schulz wieder mit dem Kopf.
Wobei das auch schon Ansätze hat. Nokia-Telefone schalten sich selbsttätig ein, um dir von einem Termin, den du gerade verpasst, von zu tun.
Sie zeigen schon, dass es auf jeden Fall geht.
Das beeindruckende wird, wenn wir alle in Zukunft lokationsbasierte Dienste verwenden, also mit unseren Mobiltelefonen durch die Stadt laufen. Lokationsbasierte Dienste sind Dienste, die nur in einem kleinen Raum angeboten werden. Also in der Friedrichstraße in Berlin laufe ich lange. Mein Telefon schaltet sich an, um mir Konzutun, dass links von mir doch ein Juwelier sah, in dem es tolles Swarovski-Ringe gäbe. Und nebenan könnte ich noch in das große Hotel irgendeiner Kette, die ich nicht mag. Und ich denke, das wird passieren. Ein Spam aufs Telefon. Mal sehen, was die Hörer dazu sagen.
Das ist dann wieder auf der großen Freiheit.
Und dann ist da drin so ein kleiner Magnet und der zieht einen auch automatisch dann in die Richtung so ein bisschen.
Und die Euro ist aus der Tasche.
Ja, richtig.
Klacker.
Genau. Das ist vielleicht so ein, das wäre auch schön, so ein Elster-Telefon, was sich dann davon macht aus seiner Tasche. Aber ich hab ja vorhin gesagt, ich freue mich, weil Martin hoffentlich noch am Telefon ist und hier steht als Stichwort für uns einfach nur drin, hat eine Lösung für das Problem. Und sowas finde ich ja immer gut. Hallo Martin. Der Martin ist natürlich schon nicht mehr da, weil er so lange gewartet hat.
Ja, das war wahrscheinlich ein Anruf aus einem kleinen Kaffee in Rigmansworth.
Ach, da müssen wir halt den Andreas nehmen, der hat nämlich ein Rat zum Thema. Hallo Andreas.
Moin, da ich ja jetzt mal viele Leute am Apparat habe, aber hoffe ich zumindest, weil Chaos Computer Club suggeriert mir das irgendwie, würde ich ganz gerne die Frage beantwortet haben, ich habe mal vor Uhrzeiten zum Thema Bouncen was gesucht. Also quasi, ich kriege Werbe-Mails und lasse sie zurückprallen und es sieht so aus, als ob meine E-Mail-Adresse gar nicht existiert. Ich habe dazu mal ein Tool gefunden, das Problem war, das funktionierte nur, wenn ich die E-Mail beim gleichen Anbieter habe, wie ich mich eingewählt habe. Quasi, er brauchte da wohl irgendwie den Server, keine Ahnung warum. Funktion bei mir nicht, weil ich über IDC ins Internet gehe, also Internet by Call, und beim großen Anbieter meine E-Mails abhole. Kennt ihr irgendwelche Möglichkeiten, wie ich das machen kann? Dass ich mich quasi tane und dass meine E-Mail-Adresse gar nicht existiert?
Da würde es wahrscheinlich selbst als Spammer abgelehnt werden oder so.
Ja, nee, es geht ja darum, wenn du meinst, wegen einer E-Mail-Adresse, du schickst einen E-Mail an jemanden, vertippst dich, dann kommt ja diese Message, dass die E-Mail-Adresse existiert gar nicht. Der Host erkennt das nicht und schickt sie dir zurück.
Das wäre natürlich die beste Lösung, hat aber das Problem, dass du natürlich zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo du entscheidest, das jetzt mal abzulehnen, auch schon dir sicher sein musst, dass diese E-Mail auch wirklich Spam ist und du nicht gerade irgendwie eine E-Mail sozusagen ablehnst, die dir wirklich hinzukommen sollen.
Ja, das ist mir schon klar.
Oder du meinst, dass du die erst anschaust und dann irgendwie einen Knopf drückst oder so, dass die ausbauen?
Das Tool hat, glaube ich, hat sich die Header runtergeladen, also die Betreffzeilen exzizit. Dann kannst du ja schon in etwa sehen, was Spam ist und was nicht. Zumindest den Großteil kannst du ja schon mal aussortieren.
Und dann konntest du es eben bouncen lassen.
Dass man natürlich praktisch mal die Mail auf dem Mailserver unter Unix liest, dann kann man sie da einfach bouncen lassen. Wenn du das nachdem du die Mails gezogen hast auf deinen Rechner tun möchtest, musst du über denselben Anbieter verbunden sein, über den die Mail ankam, damit die Bounce-Address identisch ist. Außer dein Internetanbieter erlaubt dir, mit der Adresse an die die Mail ging als Absender zu posten.
Also es gibt keine andere Möglichkeit, dass du dann jetzt mein Ding, ich wähle mich über Telekom ein, bin aber bei WebDE jetzt nur als ganz böses Beispiel, und ich kann aber nicht dann bouncen lassen. Müsste ich schon über meine Telekom-E-Mails quasi abholen.
Bietet denn WebDE einen SMTP-Server an für dich? Und dann funktioniert es nicht?
Nee, funktioniert nicht. Das Programm sagt von vornherein schon, dass es aus irgendwelchen Gründen die einmal direkt braucht. Dass ein modernes, in Anführungszeichen, ein IBC-Altzeitalter doch ein bisschen blöde ist.
Aber meinst du denn, dass es was bringt, wenn die bounst?
Ja, weil derjenige dann ja nicht weiß, dass meine E-Mail-Adresse existiert. Sie ist ja nicht vertifiziert dadurch.
Ja, aber ich glaube mal, dass die überhaupt gar nicht interessiert, ob es E-Mail-Adressen gibt oder nicht. Also ich meine, die sind ja immer irgendwo eingesammelt worden, die kommen ja irgendwo her. Dann können die auch davon ausgehen, dass es die nicht mehr gibt. Und einfach der Prozentsatz ist relativ gering. Ich glaube nicht, dass sich da jemand die Mühe macht, um irgendwie Bounces auszuwerten, oder?
Du meinst quasi, dass es nicht jemanden noch gibt, der sich dann da hinsetzt und daraus filtert, weil die E-Mail-Adresse dann nicht mehr gibt?
Von Hand bestimmt nicht. Ich weiß auch nicht.
Ich denke, es ist eher sinnvoller, die dann gleich als Abuse-Report umzuformulieren. Also gleich an den zuständigen Mail-Server-Betreiber, da wo es herkommt, dem zu schreiben, dass er da irgendwie seine Kunden mal bitte zurechtweisen soll.
Ja, obwohl das dann im Endeffekt auch wieder ein Tropfung auf dem heißen Stein ist, weil wir vorhin schon gehört haben, dass die E-Mail-Adressen dann ja auch wieder laufend wechseln.
Jaja, aber die müssen ja irgendwo eingeliefert werden. Das heißt, die brauchen einen offenen Punkt, wo sie das irgendwie ins Internet reinwerfen können. Und so eine offenen Relays, also ja, weiter Sender, die stehen halt irgendwo mal rum, weil irgendjemand hat eine Standardinstallation gemacht von einem System und da ist dann erstmal alles offen. Und der steht dann, wird dann vergessen, dann denken die Leute drei Jahre nicht mehr daran, dass dieser Rechner da irgendwie steht und vielleicht Mail ziehen und her schiebt.
Also quasi, wenn alle netten Leute sich mal vernünftig in ihre Server kommen würden, hätten wir das Problem gar nicht.
Richtig. Oder im Zweifelsfall musst du einem Administrator sagen, so oft da einer deiner Kunden hat er ein Problem. Vielleicht macht das ja auch mit Absicht. Und dann muss der ja losgehen zu seinem Kunden und sagen, du hast er. Oder ansonsten wird er einfach auch riskieren, dass er vielleicht irgendwann mal gesperrt wird und hat ein Problem mit seinen Kunden gegenüber, weil die beschweren sich natürlich, dass ihre Mails nicht mehr angenommen werden irgendwo.
Also muss ich quasi alle Server, die in der Liste stehen, in der Receive-Liste, Received From, oder wie heißt das?
Nee, nur den untersten.
Nur den untersten.
Die anderen können jetzt dafür, die haben ja dann im Prinzip, denn das ist ja im Internet unterwegs. Und dann ist es eigentlich auch erst mal okay, die anzunehmen. Auf jeden Fall nicht besonders verwerflich. Und wichtig ist der erste da, wo es eingeliefert ist, weil der muss irgendwie eine offene Tür haben.
Also mit anderen Worten, wenn ich den Server nehme, den abuse, das vorsetze, müsste er eigentlich ankommen. Wenn er dann wenigstens halbwegs vernünftig konfiguriert ist.
Und wenn der Administrator ein Interesse daran hat, einen Kunden zu verlieren, es gibt einfach auch Internet Provider, die ihr Geschäftsmodell darauf beruhen lassen, dass die Kunden haben, die große Mengen an Datenvolumen in dieses Netz spucken, namentlich Spam. Und die interessiert es dann halt im Zweifel auch nicht.
Gut, aber dann ist es der nächste Provider von denen, der sagt, also geh jetzt weg.
Also in der Regel ist es auch nicht. Also in der Regel scheitert es dann tatsächlich an der Umsetzung und es zeigt auch wieder recht deutlich, wie dringend wir doch einfach eine gesetzliche Regelung des Ganzen brauchen.
Wobei die Administratoren, die wir jetzt betroffen sind, die ärgern sich natürlich auch so. Und eigentlich müssten Admins irgendwie ein Interesse daran haben, gegen diesen ganzen Spamkram vorzugehen und die Mailserver auch dicht zu machen.
Wobei das Problem noch eigentlich ist, dass das Ganze nicht unbedingt nur aus Deutschland kommt. Also ich kriege ja nicht nur Spam aus Deutschland, das ist sogar noch der kleinste Teil.
Ja eben, also das meine ich ja, dass die Admins, da alle Admins irgendwie die Mailserver betreiben sollten, Interesse daran haben, den Spam einzudämmen, weil letztendlich ist es auch für sie wieder Arbeit.
Ja, also dreht man sich im Endeffekt im Kreis, weil es Leute gibt, die daran verdienen und Leute, die genervt sind, aber die, die daran verdienen, noch irgendwo am längeren Hebel sitzen.
Genau, weil sie die besseren Admins haben, die immer alles rumkommen.
Also es ist eigentlich ein Thema, wo man eigentlich schon jetzt sagen kann, dass es eigentlich verloren ist.
Naja, ich denke man kann dem schon eine ganze Menge Eindämmungspotenzial entgegenschieben, wenn man den nur wollte. Also zumindest diese ganzen Superharten, die sich immer wieder was einfallen lassen, die wird es immer geben. Aber es nimmt ja auch so generell zu, dass wirklich jede Firma von einem eine E-Mail-Adresse haben will und dann es natürlich nicht sein lassen kann, einem nochmal die Newsletter von ihren langweiligen Produkten zu schicken. Und nochmal und nochmal und noch. Und irgendwann schicken sie dir megabyteweise irgendwelche PDF-Katalogen und dann schicken sie dir noch Weihnachtsgrußkarten und Ostergrußkarten und keine Ahnung, was sie sich noch alles einfallen lassen. Also all dieser ganze gequöllene Scheiß, der schon immer aus dem Briefkasten rausfällt, wo es einem irgendwie nervt und nochmal ein Pizza bringen dient, das wird sich halt irgendwann in den E-Mail Boxen auch so abspielen.
Andreas, wir möchten nicht, dass du dir was antust. Ist klar, weil du so resigniert jetzt natürlich von uns scheidest.
Also es gibt, ich meine, man kann es auch positiv sehen. Ich denke mal, dass im Zuge, dass immer mehr Leute einfach auch jetzt das Internet technisch verstehen. Ich meine, die junge Generation, die letzten zehn Jahre, die haben irgendwie das meiste schon mitbekommen. Und wir werden es erleben, dass es auch in zunehmendem Maße Werkzeuge gibt, um sich eben seine eigene Burg zu bauen. Das ist aber derzeit alles noch nicht sehr weit.
Die Werkzeuge, um da durchzukommen, wenn man jetzt die Script-Kitties halt nimmt, die irgendein Programm finden und dann so ausprobieren und dann hast du eben solche netten Schwertse, wie damals mit Stacheldraht, als sie die ganzen Server versucht haben runterzufahren. Was war das? Haben sie eBay, haben sie, glaube ich, angegriffen? Vor anderthalb Jahren?
Ja, und Yahoo! haben sie angegriffen. Aber es ist nicht klar, wer das war.
Es sah ja zeitweise danach aus, dass es Script-Kitties waren, die einfach nur ein Programm gefunden hatten und selber damit gar nicht umgehen konnten.
Es könnte aber auch von einer amerikanischen Regierung gekommen sein.
Könnte aber auch nur die Frage, ob es sich um Script-Kitties handelt, die einfach nur Kitties sind oder ob es sich um Script-Kitties handelt, die halt dafür hoch bezahlt werden.
Naja, okay, wenn ihr mir nicht helfen könnt, dann muss ich da eben alleine weiter in dieser böse Welt und irgendwas finden.
Ja, das ist ja immer schon so gewesen.
Naja, gut, immerhin hab ich jetzt mal kompetente Leute am Horror gehabt, die mir dann doch sagen konnten, das ist eigentlich gar nichts selbst.
Ja, aber das ist doch auch eine Art von Bestätigung.
Alles klar, alles gut.
Wir greifen ja heute im Chaosradio Blue Moon in Sachen Spam nach jedem Strohhalm, deswegen gehen wir direkt mal über zu Simon. Hallo Simon.
Hallo.
Ja, also mein Vorvorredner hatte da sein Problem mit Spam-Mails bei ICQ und es gibt da eine Möglichkeit, diese Spam-Mails oder die Spam-Messages zu verhindern. Und zwar kann man abstellen, dass man von unbekannten Nutzern Nachrichten geschickt bekommt.
Ist das nicht generell das System bei ICQ, das so belieferungsmäßig eingestellt ist?
So viel ich weiß, gibt es das erst, oder ich weiß nicht, ob es in früheren Versionen gab, aber ich glaube nicht, ab Version 2001 Beta. Also die ganz neue Version.
Die heißt Beta, die Version.
Ja, bei ICQ heißt das irgendwie alles immer Beta. Ich habe noch keine andere als Beta gesehen, außer Alpha.
Mir geht es genauso, ich habe auch noch nie eine Release-Version von irgendeinem ICQ Software gesehen.
Genau, aber man kann es eben abstellen. Ich habe es zwar nicht gemacht bei mir, ich kriege auch ab und zu irgendwelche tollen Messages von wegen komme auf die Seite und bla. Aber der Nachteil ist natürlich daran, wenn irgendjemand Neues eine Nachricht schicken will, kriegt man die natürlich nicht mehr.
Genau, die Kontaktaufnahme ist halt schwierig von außen. Man gibt halt irgendwie die Adresse weg, vielleicht auf einer Visitenkarte und möchte eben auch angeschrieben werden.
Genau, und da wäre dann das Problem dabei. Allerdings, wenn er eben das Problem hat, dass da wirklich so viel kommt, wie er gesagt hat, da hat er von wegen kurz nicht angewiesen und schon acht neue Nachrichten, denke ich, da ist bei ihm dann wahrscheinlich nicht sinnvoll, das dann einzustellen.
Vielleicht ist deine Nummer auch einfach auf die falsche Webseite geraten.
Ist auch möglich, aber meine Nummer zum Beispiel kann eigentlich auch nicht auf die falsche Webseite geraten sein und ich kriege trotzdem so eine Nachrichten erst seit kurzem. Joa, schon eine Weile. Schon bestimmt vier Jahre oder so. Na ja, nicht ganz so lang. Drei Jahre durften es sein. Immer die gleiche.
Es nimmt halt auch zu. Wir nehmen das auch so wahr, dass irgendwie so im letzten Jahr, letzten halben Jahr, es irgendwie beginnt auf Pfleger zu werden. Ich weiß nicht genau woran es liegt, aber irgendwie drehen sie jetzt glaube ich alle durch.
Bei diesen ICQ-Diensten ist ein Psychoeffekt ein ganz ganz dummer. Tatsache ist nämlich, dass man im Vergleich zu Mail, da sich das um so ein Direktkontaktsystem handelt, immer eher das Gefühl hat, es könnte wirklich eine Person dahinter stecken, die einem da was fragen möchte, weil das so die Tendenz des Netzes ist. Jeder fragt jeden nach irgendwas. Und wenn es dann nicht direkt irgendwelche Aufnahmeversuche erotischer Art sind oder erotomaner, dann merkt man das manchmal nicht so genau und denkt sich, okay, könnte ja Petra sein, die ich damals in Düsseldorf kennengelernt habe. Und die ist das dann aber überhaupt nicht.
Weil das Lustige war, dass ich letztens mal so jemanden angesprochen habe. Er soll das doch bitte unterlassen. Und der dann darauf auch wirklich reagiert hat. Also ich dachte immer, da sitzen dann irgendwelche Leute mit ihrem Programm hinter und schicken massenweise Messages an, weiß ich, wie viel in ihrer Liste aufgeführten Leute. Und das war auch der erste, der dann plötzlich geantwortet hat. Und er hat mir dann erzählt, er wäre Tina oder so ein Kram. Und naja, er hat es dann doch irgendwann nach einigen Beleidigungen meinerseits unterlassen, wieder zurückzuschreiben.
Das kann man dir durchaus vorstellen. Aber ich finde, das ist ja dann eher sowas wie diese tragikomische Geschichte, wenn der Kollege, der da am anderen Ende der Leitung sitzt, tatsächlich sagt, pass mal auf, ich mach das auch nur als Job, ich glaub, ich werd dafür bezahlt, ich krieg dafür vielleicht 500 Netto im Monat und dafür schreib ich halt auch nur allen Leuten die E-Mails. Kennst du die jungen Frauen, die die Autos immer aufschreiben in der Innenstadt? Das ist ein ähnliches Phänomen, aber...
Das ähnliche Phänomen würde ich darauf beziehen, die lädten Leute, die am Callcenter sitzen und irgendwelche fremden Leute anrufen müssen und die befragen und auch dafür Geld kriegen. Das ist auch so eine Sache, denke ich, die man damit irgendwie in Bezug ziehen kann.
Ja, sozusagen. Wir machen ja auch im Grunde eine Art von Spam, aber uns kann man ja abschalten, das finde ich ganz günstig.
Und zur allgemeinen Statistik nochmal hinzufügen, kriege ich natürlich auch über Mail Spam der XXX-Version, wo ich mich auch frage, wie die meine E-Mail erhalten. Und über Handy bekomme ich auch schon ab und zu jetzt Spam-Mails.
Hast du auch schon eine Fax-Spam bekommen?
Nee, noch nicht. Aber allerdings gehört die Fax-Nummer auf meinem Vater. Also da weiß ich nicht, was der kriegt.
Okay, Kollege.
Dann machen wir mal ein bisschen Musik.
Das würde ich auch vorschlagen. Und dann probieren wir uns weiter in Problemlösungen. Kommt zu Jua. Witz. Schon ein Trädchen rausgequetscht.
Wo waren wir denn stehen geblieben?
Wir waren eigentlich bei ICQ stehen geblieben und da können wir auch eben noch ein Stückchen weitermachen. Vielleicht gibt es ja trotzdem noch einen Tipp, der wirklich zieht und zwar von Frank. Hallo Frank.
Ja also ich möchte noch was ergänzen zu meinem Vorredner. Und zwar ich bin nicht ganz sicher, wie es geht, weil ich bin jetzt eigentlich LICQ, weil ich Linux hab, aber man kann noch irgendwie abschalten, dass man so Mass-Messages kriegt. Also es gibt unter ICQ so ein System, das funktioniert im Prinzip wie ein E-Mail-Verteiler, dass man eine Message an verschiedene Verteiler schickt. Und das kann man abschalten und dann gibt es noch irgendwie eine Pager-Funktion, also Web-Pager-Funktionen, die man abschalten kann. Also es findet man eigentlich alles, wenn man mal auf Security und Privacy geht bei ICQ. So ist das sehr nützlich, weil man da auch abschalten kann bei dem ganz neuen ICQ, dass die Daten irgendwie an Tritte weitergegeben werden, also wenn sich da mal Leute wundern.
Sind das jetzt Features nur von diesem Linux ICQ Client oder sind das Features?
Nee, das sind von dem Windows ICQ Client, weil nämlich von diesem Linux ICQ Client, da kommt irgendwie gar keine Spam an. Ich weiß nicht, was die anders machen. Das ist total spamfrei. Aber ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt. Und dann gibt es noch für die Leute, wo trotzdem noch Spam kriegen, da gibt es noch so Tools, die nennen sich ICQ, die Flutter. Die löschen dann einfach alle ungelesenen Nachrichten, weil es ja ziemlich ewig dauern kann, bis man da mal alles weggeklickt hat, was da kam mit irgendwelchem Spam. Also wenn da einer da mal alles voll hat, dann kann er so eine Flutter installieren. Man muss natürlich aufpassen, dass da nicht auch ein kleines Hintertürchen drin ist oder so.
Klar, da hat man hinterher zehn Programme, bei denen man allen aufpassen muss, dass man überall die Dinger richtig konfiguriert hat, was natürlich auch viel Arbeit macht.
Ja, was halt auch noch ein Problem von iCQ ist, iCQ schickt immer die IP-Adresse mit. Also es ist dann auch ziemlich einfach, die dann rauszufiltern. Und dann kann man, weil auch iCQ eben im Normalfall über so Peer-to-Peer-Networken funktioniert und nicht über einen Server schickt. Und was ich denke mal, da ist viel Spamming angesagt bei iCQ, weil es halt auch sich immer mehr verbreitet.
Jo, ich wollte noch mal was sagen und zwar Thema Spam Filtering unter Windows. Und zwar gibt es dann das geniale kleine Tool Hamster, nennt sich das. Ich weiß nicht, ob das irgendwer kennt.
Hamster? Ich nicht.
Hamster ist ein ja eigentlich privater Mail und News Server mit einer ziemlich guten Scriptsprache. Das heißt, man kann selbstständig bestimmen, welche E-Mail Accounts möchte ich abrufen, wie viele E-Mails Accounts möchte ich abrufen, welche News Server abrufen etc. Und unter anderem hat das auch, ich muss mir hier noch mal kurz durchklicken bei mir. Das läuft nur sämtlich im Windows OS. Also unter XP kann ich es noch nicht testen, aber ansonsten unter allen anderen läuft das. Hat unter anderem auch einen schönen Kiel-File, wie es auch einige News und ähnliche Reader haben. Wo man dann direkt eintragen kann im Kiel-File, welche E-Mail, welches Subjekt, welches From soll down-discord werden etc. Und die werden einfach nicht runtergeladen. Man kann noch einstellen, dass man entweder sie gleich vom Server löscht oder dass sie eben nur auf dem Server verbleiben und man kriegt nur eine kleine Nachricht, die und die E-Mail mit dem und dem Header wurde gelöscht.
Es handelt sich um einen eigenen Mailserver, er holt die Mail schon, bekommt sie per SMTP überreicht oder er holt sie sich von einem Mailserver?
Er holt sie sich selber ab, also nur ein kleines Windows-Programm, was im Trail läuft.
Also wie ein Mailproxy, mehr oder weniger.
Genau, mehr oder weniger Proxy, ja, weniger Server. Ist auch gut für kleinere Netze, d.h. man kann immer auf jedem Kleinten entsprechend die E-Mails abrufen, läuft auch mit allen anderen Betriebssystemen zusammen, wenn man im Netzwerk eben auf den...
D.h. er holt sie, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, er holt sie mit Pop oder E-Map-Protokoll und stellt sie auch per Pop oder E-Map bereit oder macht er nur Pop?
Genau, also Pop macht er, E-Map hab ich noch nie ausprobiert, glaube nicht.
Ah, auf beiden Seiten nicht?
Auf beiden Seiten leider nicht.
Man kommt ja vielleicht irgendwann noch mal dazu. Das ist eigentlich eine sehr praktische Anwendung, finde ich. Also das ist schon irgendwie eine relativ elegante Lösung.
So ein Mailproxy.
Ja, man holt es einfach, man muss nicht wirklich einen richtigen Mailserver betreiben, aber man hat zumindest irgendwie seine Mail auch zentral. Und wenn man eben auf den Rechner, wo es drauf ist, auch noch per Internet zugreifen kann, hat man eben auch von überall Internet.
Das heißt, der private User macht es sich ganz einfach und kauft sich zu dem Rechner, den er sich mühsam zusammengespart hat, einfach noch einen dazu, den er dann davor stellte?
Ist möglich, also ich habe ihn jetzt lokal laufen, ist einfacher, kann jedoch auf dem 2. oder 3. Rechner, wenn ich meinen hätte, könnte ich die auch ohne Probleme abrufen.
Ist es denn komfortabler als jetzt irgendwie in einem Mailprogramm Vete einzurichten?
Ja, meiner Meinung schon. Also ich benutze, auch schon auf meinem Hauptoutlook, das kann man damit unter anderem auch verschleiern, man kann die gesamten Heller anpassen und ähnliche Sachen. Es gibt noch etliche Zusatztools, das Ganze ist freeware und außerdem ist die Source verfügbar. Das heißt, man kann da auch gleich rumgucken. Klar, das ist das übliche www.tglsoft.de, das ist direkt von dem eigentlichen Entwickler, beziehungsweise der es übernommen hat.
Ist ziemlich komfortabel, muss ich sagen.
Danke für den Tipp, Manuel.
Kein Problem.
Mal schauen, ob die Birgit ausgeharrt hat. Hallo Birgit. Nö, Birgit hat nicht ausgeharrt. Die hat auch Massen-E-Mails bekommen und beschäftigt sich jetzt wahrscheinlich schon wieder mit dem Löschen. Christian, hallo. Hallo? Ah, Begeisterung am anderen in der Leitung. Hallo?
Jetzt darfst du sprechen.
Vielleicht hört er uns gar nicht.
Hallo.
Hallo, Christian. Hallo?
Ja, fang doch einfach an zu reden.
Ich war mir jetzt nicht an sicher, weil ich hab hier schon seit, naja, 2 Stunden gewartet. Also, ich lasse das erstmal folgendem, den kann ich doch in diese Liste einreihen mit den ersten Leuten von Winx Spam und so. Aber dann wollen wir nur auf den nächsten. Nee, nee, natürlich Spam bekommen. Also Spam verschicken, nee, nee. So schlimm bin ich nur wirklich nicht. Also, das wäre ja schlimm. Ich kasse ja auch so eine Leute. Nee, ich kriege halt Spam und auch ziemlich heftig und auch allen möglichen Scheiß, von Lebensversicherungen bis hier der buzwanische Präsident von bla bla bla. Ich bräuchte mal wieder ein bisschen Geld, damit er aus dem Knast kommt und dann halt wie man jetzt potentiiert und all der Scheiß. Nee, jetzt wirklich.
Also ich weiß auch nicht, wo das herkommt.
Ich hab da allen möglichen Kack jeden Tag. Ich kriege jeden Tag bestimmt fünf Spam-Mails.
Nur benutze zwar auch Outlook.
Ich weiß, es ist nicht so toll, aber dir fällt mir immer noch am besten und dann hau ich die halt immer gleich raus. Ein Zit, was ich erst mal kurz zur Outlook sagen wollte, weil vorhin einer fragte, neben diesem Active Scripting kann man auch einfach irgendwo unter den Optionen diese, glaube ich, Vorschauansicht oder irgendwie so heißt das, deaktivieren. Das heißt, man hat ja normalerweise das dreietalte Fenster, also, ne, vierietalze. Links diese Ordner und dann noch die Kontakte und oben dann halt auf der rechten Seite die Mails und darunter die Vorschauansicht. Wenn man diese Vorschauansicht rausnimmt, dann wird zwar diese HTML-Code nicht deaktiviert, aber dann werden die nicht direkt eröffnet. Also sind halt nur die Mails zu sehen. Und deshalb, wenn man das rausnimmt, dann kann man damit zumindest schon mal verhindern, dass sich sofort die Dinge aktivieren, weil ja sonst immer automatisch die oberste Mail geöffnet wird von Outlook. Das ist sinnvoll. Ja, das wäre jetzt nur so ein kleiner Tipp. Aber worauf ihr euch eigentlich aufmerksam machen wollt, ist, ich hab da so eine Seite im Internet gefunden, und zwar auf einer privaten T-Online-Seite. Da hat einer da eine nette Parodie zu diesen ganzen Kettenmails geschrieben. Also eher Kettenmails, jetzt nicht so die, wie heißt das hier, nicht Spam, sondern Kettenmails. Das ist auch Spam.
Die sind auch zusammen.
Ja, aber klar, es ist jetzt noch ein bisschen was anderes, aber wie gesagt, Kettenmails halt. Und die Sache ist so, das wird aus meiner Sicht echt so das Beste ist, um jemanden, der so eine Scheiße irgendwie macht, zu bekehren, weil ich könnte euch jetzt mal die Adresse durchsagen, falls ihr euch aufschreiben oder selber schnell angucken wollt.
Na sag mal.
Also das Home-Punkt, wie man es kennt, home.online.de Ja.
Dann slash home.
Dann slash olga.
Bindestrich.
Mach mal, wir können dir schon folgen.
Also olga-stift, dann wieder slash und dann wtr.html. Und wenn du das jetzt alles richtig eingetippt hast, dann müsstet ihr jetzt auf so eine Seite kommen, wo halt so um wtr steht und dann kommt halt einfach nur so ein Text dazu mit diesen ganzen scheiß Kettenmails und der ist aus meiner Sicht sehr gut gemacht. Ganz einfach, weil der einerseits diese ganze Sache auch verurteilt hat, aber besonders sehr lustig gemacht ist. Also sozusagen jeder, der den liest.
Ist der mit dem Hamster vergiftet oder sowas? Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Christian, natürlich, lass doch mal die Katze aus dem Sack, der gibt dir die Adresse an. Das kann sich doch eh keiner merken. Christian, liest doch mal ein Häppchen davon vor, wenn du es schon gern hast.
Na, dann les ich euch jetzt mal den besten Absatz vor. Also dritter Punkt. Hallöchen da draußen, dieser Kettenbrief, also der erzählt halt so weiter, für Arten von Kettenbrief, gibt Hallöchen da draußen. Dieser Kettenbrief existiert seit 1998 und 97 so rum. Das ist absolut unglaublich, weil es damals noch gar keine E-Mails gab. Und so funktioniert es. Schick ihn innerhalb der nächsten sieben Minuten an 15.067 Leute weiter, von denen du denkst, sie könnten ihn gebrauchen. Sonst erstens bizarres Horror-Szenario Nr. 1, sonst noch bizarres Horror-Szenario Nr. 2, sonst extrem bizarres Horror-Szenario Nr. 3.
War das verständlich?
Wenn du Kettenbriefe bekommst, die dir androhen, umgepuppt und glücklos zu bleiben, lösche sie. Wenn sie wenigstens lustig sind, schick sie weiter an Leute, von denen du denkst, sie teilen dein Humor. Geh nicht anderen Lottoer auf den Wecker, in dem du ihnen ein schlechtes Gewissen wegen eines Leprakranken in Bozwaner machst, der noch dazu keine Zähne hat und seit 27 Jahren auf dem Rücken eines toten Elefanten festgebunden ist und dessen einzige Chance jede weitere weitergeleitete Mail ist, o andernfalls eine Mondraket in dein Vorgarten stürzt. Danke.
Ich meine, die Leute schicken es natürlich trotzdem weiter und dann ist es auch wieder spam. Weil es leider zu lustig ist, als es für sich zu machen ist.
Das ist richtig, ja klar, aber das ist aus meiner Sicht der Fall. Ich muss dazu sagen, ich hatte vor einiger Zeit, oder was heißt vor einiger Zeit, war vor gut zwei Jahren, die Sache, wie es wahrscheinlich vielen Leuten passiert, sprich 1. Klasse. Einige Leute aus deiner Klasse gehen sowieso von der Schule ab und einige gehen nach Amerika und der Rest bleibt halt in Deutschland. Und naja, dann war da halt diese Sache, dass einige Leute auf diesem Trip mal von wegen, oh, mir hat hier einer geschrieben, wenn ich diese Mail weiterleite, kriege ich ein Nokia-Handy und hier schenkt mir ein Bill Gates 100 Dollar.
Worum es übrigens in diesem Text auch geht.
Und dann auch von wegen, ja, wenn man das hier weiterleitet, dann wird man ganz glücklich.
Das haben doch jetzt alle begriffen, oder? Das haben doch jetzt alle begriffen, oder? Da draußen, also dass man sowas irgendwie nicht und...
Genau, naja, und ich meinte plötzlich, ich hab dann halt diesen komischen Text mal einfach an die alle geschickt und von da an war dann Ruhe, weil die irgendwie alle begriffen haben, okay, also ich mein sicher, das ist dann auch irgendwie wieder eine Kettenmail, aber dann haben sie wenigstens begriffen, diesen anderen Scheiß nicht zu senden und dann war halt erst mal Ruhe und das ist aus meiner Sicht so ein bisschen wenigstens eine kleine Art von Bekehrung.
Das erinnert mich an diesen Good Times Virus, da war es ja auch ähnlich. Es war ja lange Zeit, wurde irgendwie auch immer per E-Mails und solchen Mastenkettenbriefen von dem Good Times Virus gewarnt, der ja ganz grausame Dinge tut, irgendwie deine Freundin ausführt, und alle haben es halt geglaubt und da dann auf die Webseite zu verweisen, wo über diesen Hoax aufgeklärt wurde, hat meistens auch schon ein bisschen geholfen. Aber später kamen ja dann die bösen Viren, die das dann tatsächlich getan haben und dann gucken wir alle.
Na ja, ansonsten könnte man halt nur sagen, entweder klüger werden, oder wer gar keine Ahnung hat, im Internet gucken, weil was er auch von uns erzählt hat, diese Sache mit den Horrocks und den Headern und Flex und so, dazu findet man ja eigentlich genug Insider-Informationen, die auch so für Anfänger verständlich sind im Netz. Man muss halt nur ein bisschen gucken.
Das bringt mich auch darauf, mal auf ein Dokument zu verweisen, was sehr, sehr, sehr alt ist. Eine der ältesten Niederschriften im Internet, die Netiquette, die ist ein bisschen in Vergessenheit geraten. Eigentlich ein sehr kluger, kurzer Text, der kurz zusammengefasst sagt, irgendwie bin ich nicht ordentlich im Internet und irgendwie halte ich ein bisschen zurück. Und auch wie man sich irgendwie an Diskussionen beteiligen soll, dass man nicht gleich auf jeder neuen Mailingliste erst mal laut losschreit und rumfragt und vielleicht auch erst mal eine Weile mitliest, um die Kultur so festzustellen. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir da demnächst irgendwann noch mal ein bisschen Entspannung sehen. Viele der Probleme, die in den letzten fünf Jahren aufgetreten sind, so in der Gesamtkultur des Internets, waren natürlich vor allem dadurch bedingt, dass das Netz lange, lange Zeit zu 95% Neueinsteigern und nur zu 5% aus halbwegs erfahrenen Menschen bestand, weil einfach dermaßen viele Leute dazugestoßen sind. Sicherlich ist die Zahl der Neueinsteiger immer noch sehr hoch, aber zumindest gibt es jetzt immer mehr Leute, die zumindest schon einige Jahre Erfahrung haben.
Aber ich finde, gerade dann, wenn man das erste halbe Jahr rumgestiefelt ist, findet man in der Regel, wenn man neu im Geschäft ist und die Netiquette nicht kennt, Geschmack daran, diesen Anonymitätsbonus wirklich auszunutzen und den Leuten das beizubringen, halte ich für relativ schwierig.
Den Anonymitätsbonus auszunutzen?
Naja, so dieses Ding, ihr könnt mich können, ihr könnt mich erstmal laut losfroßen, verstehst du? Alter, du gehst mir von Sack, du gehst mir von Sack, der Tim geht mir auch von Sack und keiner kennt mich, verstehst du? Und das finden die Leute toll.
Die haben dann so komische Mailadressen wie druid5000.gmx, dann kommt aber halt irgendwie gleich Mailadresse, alles kommt dann halt wieder nach.
Irgendwann werden sie dann feststellen, dass sie eben doch so anonym im Internet nicht sind, sondern das ist eher das Gegenteil der Fall ist. Wenn man irgendwie den notwendigen Zugriffsraum hat, irgendwie bei den Servern und wenn man vielleicht einem Unternehmen angehört, was in der Lage ist, mal eben irgendwelche grauen Zettel irgendwo hinzuschicken und schon stehen alle stramm, geben einem die Festplatten, die man haben will, da ist es halt mit der Anonymität nicht sehr weit her. Das haben wir ja letzten September ganz schön gesehen, wo ja dann auch alle Universitäten erst mal schön brav irgendwie ihre Lokfals ausgehändigt haben und ja und nein und natürlich könnt ihr noch mal reinschauen und da ist ja alles für die Rastafaren.
Apropos Lokfals, weil vorhin dieser Begriff, man kann mit dem Header machen, was man will, viel, es gibt doch auch sogenannte Remailer, oder? Da hab ich mir mal irgendwie einen runtergeladen, das ist sowas, da nimmt einem im Grunde alle Arbeit ab und geht so weit, dass er einem wirklich diesen Header tatsächlich auch so bastelt, dass der Provider da gar nichts mit zu tun hat, also der, über den man arbeitet, gar nichts mit zu tun hat. Da steht dann wirklich mal lotki.fbi.com und so kommt das beim anderen auch an und der kann nur feststellen, dass es das nicht ist, wenn er den Header wirklich öffnet.
Also die Remailer, die machen das eigentlich, die sagen dann, es ist von einem Remailer. Aber diese Remailer sind für Spammer eigentlich viel zu aufwendig, würde ich sagen. Dann musst du denn Sachen ausfüllen und also diese Einlieferungsprozesse eigentlich komplizierter dazu. Sperren die anonymen Remailer, denke ich, einfach mal nach fünf Mails mit dem gleichen Inhalt, sperren die einfach für eine Weile oder so was. Die haben dann natürlich schon Schutzmechanismen, die sind ja auch nicht blöd.
Ich hab ja mal gelesen, das fand ich ja die schönste Verschwörungstheorie seit langem, dass diese ganzen Remailer und diese anonymen Boards, die unterhalten werden im Internet und wo die Leute immer denken, sie könnten sich wirklich anonyme über Sachen unterhalten, von CIA und ähnlichen Organisationen unterhalten werden, um herauszufinden, genau wer eben halt anonymen bleiben möchte. Und das fand ich ganz spaßig.
Also die Sperma benutzt natürlich letztlich genau die gleichen Techniken wie diese Remailer auch. Weil auch die sind nur ganz normale Computer im Internet. Das ist eben der Punkt. Man muss halt nur irgendwo ein Loch finden, wo man irgendwie die Mail erstmal reingeschossen bekommt im Internet und das ist so schwierig eben nicht. Das lässt sich zwar bekämpfen und da wird ja auch was dagegen getan und mag auch Verbesserungen mit sich bringen. Bloß das Problem ist irgendwie nicht weg.
Wir hatten vorhin mal angesprochen, das Thema Bouncing, ich hoffe Lutz ist noch dran, der wollte da was zu sagen.
Ich treib mich ja ganz viel im Usenet rum und da wird man dann nach einer ganzen Weile schon mit Spam ein bisschen überhäuft. Und da muss ich sagen, ein Programm, das quasi einen Bounc rausschickt, hat mir da sehr große Dienste geleistet. Das Ding heißt BSM 18 und schickt einfach den HIDA mit dem gesamten Inhalt zurück und sagt hallo, die Adresse gibt's hier gar nicht. Und wenn man das konsequent eine ganze Weile lang macht, hat man wirklich für eine Weile lang Ruhe.
Was ist das für ein Programm?
Das ist ein Windows-Programm, ganz kleines nur, trägt sich auch nirgendwo ein. Das ist wie ein kleines E-Mail-Programm selbst. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wo ich es her hab, vielleicht einfach mal bei Google gucken. BSM 18.
Hört sich ja militärisch an, weißt du.
Nee, nee, das B steht für Bouncing oder was weiß ich. Das N-Boot für Mail, ich weiß es nicht mehr so genau. Aber das hab ich ein Dreivierteljahr lang recht erfolgreich gemacht. Und da hab ich zumindest zwei, drei E-Mail-Adressen wieder richtig frei gekriegt.
Was meinst du mit frei gekriegt? Wie viel Spam kam vorher und danach sah es wie aus?
Ja gut, ich wechsle die E-Mail-Adressen im Usenet sowieso, in gewissen Turnos. Und dann lass ich sie liegen. Und dann schick ich dann die Bounces zurück. Und dann war nach einem halben Jahr Ruhe. Nach einem halben Jahr kam dann nichts mehr an.
Usenet sollte man vielleicht kurz erläutern, was damit gemeint ist. Das Usenet ist halt die Sammlung aller Newsgroups. Das Usenet gab es, bevor es das Internet in der heutigen Form überall gab. Da wurde halt auch mit Mail und eben mit diesen Newsgroups, mit diesen schwarzen Brettern, sind eigentlich der beste Vergleich.
Und die werden eben leider recht regelmäßig gescannt nach E-Mail-Adressen. Und da hab ich mir dann eben so eine Strategie zurechtgelegt, also halbjährlich die Adressen zu wechseln im Usenet und dann die eine Weile lang liegen zu lassen und dann was dann an Spam kam, einfach mit diesem Bounce-Programm zurückzuschicken.
Was macht dir das Leben nicht gerade leichter?
Etwas aufwendig, das ist richtig. Zumal man dann per Hand, also per drag and drop, den Header und die eigentliche Nachricht wieder in das Programm reinkopieren muss.
Da muss ich sagen, das fand ich auch ganz ziemlich blöd damals. Wir haben ja vorhin mal, ist jetzt ein paar Minuten, hier über Netiquette gesprochen. Und tatsächlich ist ja so, dass die Netiquette besagt, dass man bitte in einem Board seinen richtigen Namen und auch seine richtige E-Mail-Adresse angeben soll. Ich hab damals bei so einem Uniserver das mal gemacht. Da ging es um so einen Games-Bereich, wo halt alle ihre Nix benutzt haben, die sie auch als Spieler auftreten. Und der wirklich jeden Einzelnen angepisst hat, man solle doch bitte seinen richtigen Namen verwenden, weil es sich um die Netiquette handelt. Aber das ist halt ein Problem, das würde ich gar nicht wollen, sondern lieber einen Nick angeben, damit nicht mein Name auch noch mit einer E-Mail-Adresse verbunden werden kann.
Na ja, ich bin ein alter Verfechter des Usenets und auch der Netiquette da. Bis auf ganz besondere Ausnahmen, wo es wirklich Sinn macht, dass man nicht realen Namen und E-Mail-Adresse angibt, in sehr sensiblen Bereichen, also Selbsthilfegruppen oder was weiß ich. Aber ansonsten bin ich da auch einer, der dann eher jemanden empöbelt, wenn er nicht so einen realen Namen benutzt. Allein aus der Erfahrung heraus, dass Leute, die nicht unter ihrem realen Namen auftauchen, einfach viel mehr rumprollen und viel mehr Unsinn da machen, in DANG gerade wieder sehr gut zu beobachten. In DANG.
D-A-N-G? D-A-User?
D-A-User-Grooves. Da ging ich jetzt gerade wieder um den RFD und den CFV für die... Na. Scheiße, ich heiße die Gruppe. New User Questions und die Moderation. Und da ist der Teufel los gewesen in der Gruppe. Und dann nennen die sich NetCop-Jäger. Und da ist ein Ton dann zum Teil, das ist wirklich nicht mehr christlich. Unglaublich. Und dann muss man halt seinen Filter wieder dermaßen aufblähen.
Wie groß ist dein Kill-File?
Das kann ich gar nicht sagen. Also wenn ich so durchs Krollen, ist eine ganze Menge drin. Druckige Einträge hab ich da mindestens.
Das sind nur E-Mail-Adressen?
Nein, das sind nur die Namen aus den Newsgroups. Das sind keine E-Mail-Adressen.
Auf die realen Namen matchst du?
Beziehungsweise dann diese pseudonymen Namen, unter denen die auftreten, kombinieren mit E-Mail-Adresse.
Dann benutzt man wahrscheinlich auch immer wieder die gleichen.
Das hilft wahrscheinlich.
Ja, nach drei Tagen haben sie schon wieder andere Namen.
Wir hatten ja letztens so eine Diskussion.
Entschuldigung, mich interessiert gerade mal, um ein bisschen vom Thema abzukommen, wie lange benutzt du schon Newsnet?
Ruhig müsste ich jetzt lange zurück sagen, 96, 97, irgendwas.
Was hat, aber du hast aber auch schon, und damit hast du auch mit Internet angefangen in der Zeit?
Nee, Internet hatte ich früher. Also ich komm eigentlich aus der Mailbox-Szene. Und Internet wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht erst. Bin da so reingestolpert, damals über CompuSurf. Und dann auch über CompuSurf zu den Newsgroups gekommen. Zu der Zeit, wo es da allerdings noch etwas ruhiger und gesitterter zuging.
Die Usenet. Hatten wir tatsächlich schon mal auf der Liste. Aber lohnt sicherlich auch mal wieder. Das halte ich auch für super interessant. Mal sich im Usenet, das merkt man auch an deinem Anruf, eine Menge Leute rumtreiben, die das Internet auch auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise benutzen. Die sich mehr als Teil des Netzes verstehen, als Benutzer des Netzes. Die nicht vor dem Internet sitzen und dann mal drin sind, sondern die einfach sowieso schon immer sich als Teil des Ganzen verstanden haben. Und dort ist einfach auch eine andere Kultur anzutreffen. Die ist auch nicht unbedingt zu empfehlen immer, aber...
Ich muss sagen, das lässt leider etwas nach. Durch den ganzen Run und wenn dann irgendjemand mal in so einer, weißte geier, in irgendeinem Forum irgendwas sagt, hier Jungs, geht mal ins Usenet, da kriegt ihr tolle Antworten. Und die hauen da rein, ohne die Detikett gelesen zu haben, ohne sich an irgendwelche Spielregeln zu halten.
Für die ist das mehr eine Support-Hotline.
Ja, so diese Hippengang-Geschichten einfach. Und die lesen nicht mal die Postings der letzten Woche und stellen eine Frage nur zum 25. Mal. Und da werden die Leute natürlich auch ein bisschen ungehalten manchmal.
Das ist auch verständlich. Aber man merkt es halt schon auf, sagen wir mal, auf wissenschaftlichen Gruppen. Umso technisch es wird, umso uninteressanter, das jetzt, sagen wir mal, für den normalen Netzproll ist, umso freundlicher wird auch der Umgangston.
Das ist richtig.
Das ist wirklich außerordentlich freundlich im aufgeschlossenen Verhalten.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Man stellt dann halt fest, dass es Leute gibt, die tatsächlich noch Grammatik beherrschen.
Also ich erinnere mich auch noch wirklich gut an die Zeit, als das mit den Werbemails im Newsnet überhaupt erst losging. Das war von vornherein eine relativ starke Front dagegen. Und es wurde eigentlich auch ziemlich schnell weggeknibelt so an den ersten...
Also in dem Zusammenhang vielleicht ganz interessant auch zu erwähnen, es gibt ja auch im Newsnet die entsprechenden Gruppen. Zum Beispiel wie lerne ich Header lesen. Es gibt ja auch diese Gruppen, die um UC und Spam gehen.
Nimm noch mal ein paar Gruppen, das ist vielleicht mal ganz gut.
Ach Gott, ich hab die jetzt nicht im Kopf. Ich lese sie momentan auch nicht mit. Aber das ist ja hierarchisch aufgegedet, das ist leicht, sicher leicht finden. Im Augenblick so 15.
15 regelmäßig?
Ja. Aber das ist alles sehr durcheinander, alles Mögliche. Also viele, DE Sock Recht, DE Sock Familie Väter, also auch solche Sachen. Nicht nur Technik und so ein Kram.
Was ist dein Lieblings-Newsgroup?
Meine Haupt-Newsgroup ist DE Sock Familie Väter. Tatsächlich.
Da gibts so wenig Werbemails.
Und was hältst du von alt.talk.bizar?
Da wird mir einfach zu wie Dummfug geschrieben. Diese ganzen Talkgruppen sind irgendwie furchtbar.
Ich hab gerade einen neuen Buchtitel erfunden. Heder lesen lernen in 21 Tagen.
Ja, dann solltest du schnell mal bei Data-Backer anrufen oder bei Markt und Technik, die sind für solche Sachen immer sehr zuhahnend.
Tatsächlich haben wir hier jetzt ein bisschen Platz in unserer kleinen Telefonbox gefunden, weil die Leute relativ lange gewartet haben. Entschuldigen wir uns immer für, aber solche Themen werden ja nicht übers Knie gebrochen und innerhalb von 35 Sekunden erzählt. Das heißt, für den Fall, dass ihr euch noch was auf der Seele brennen sollte in Berlin und Brandenburg, 0331 70 97 110 zum Thema Spam. Alles jungfräulich hier. Das heißt, man kann wieder voll loslegen und sich tatsächlich noch am Thema beteiligen. 0331 70 97 110.
Eine ganz besondere Eigenart von Spam oder richtig ärgerliche Sache sind diese 190er-Dialer, die jetzt vermehrt kommen. Das heißt, die kommen also per Mail, werden ja entweder direkt geschickt oder es geht so eine HTML-Mail auf und dann geht ein Fenster auf und noch ein Fenster, noch ein Fenster. Und dann ist da irgendwie noch ein, geht dann ein Pop-Name von meinem Windows ein Fenster auf und da steht dann irgendwie nur noch was OK oder Ja. Und dann, ja, es gibt halt Leute, die klicken dann da auf irgendwie OK oder Ja, keine Ahnung und dann wird irgendwas installiert und plötzlich wird meine Internetverbindung über eine 090 Nummer und die dann irgendwie zwei Euro pro Minute oder mehr vielleicht auch irgendwie bis zu 300 Euro pro Einwahl kostet, gibt es auch.
300?
300 Euro pro Einwahl.
Es gibt 090 Nummern, die drei...
Es gibt freitarifierbare 090 Nummern.
Frei im Sinne von 300 Euro?
300 Euro und wir haben sowas noch nicht.
Also ruft uns alle 090.
987654.
Aber das ist tatsächlich ein Problem mit diesem Okay, weil ich mich an, und ich führe da immer wieder gerne meinen Vater an, als er mich angerufen hat und ich mit ihm zusammen was installiert habe. Und er, ich hatte ihm dieses Programm gesagt, er hat sich das tatsächlich auch runtergeladen, alles soweit so gut so schön, und er hat das dann installiert und rief eine halbe Stunde später an, weil er meinte, er käme mit dieser Installation nicht weiter und nur mal so viel zum Übersetzungsverständnis. Der Mann ist Lehrer, nicht? Also der Mann ist Lehrer. Da stand in dem Text, wenn Sie insgesamt jetzt mit der Installation fertig sind, dann drücken Sie bitte auf OK. Und er so, es geht nicht, es ist hier. Und ich dachte jetzt, was haben die gemacht? Ist das ein Fenster, wo vielleicht der Knopf irgendwie verschwindet unterm Rand? Ich dachte total komplex, ich sag, was steht denn da? Ja, da steht fertig und abbrechen. Ja, die haben doch gesagt, ich soll auf OK drücken. Da werden wirklich so Schritte, die er von seinen Schülern erwartet, nicht gemacht.
Ja, aber ich kann ihn gut verstehen.
Es ist aber auch total doof. Ja, es ist furchtbar.
Oder die Buttons auch jedes Mal an einer anderen Stelle sind mit einer anderen semantischen Bedeutung. Okay, wandert da irgendwie mal nach links, mal nach rechts, mal in die Mitte.
Ja, oder wenn sie sich nicht entschließen können, diese Installation doch nicht abzubrechen und weiterzuführen, wenn sie das später machen wollen im Internet, dann drücken sie jetzt bitte auf nein. Wenn sie sich entschieden haben dafür, dann auf vielleicht und dann auf später oder later. Dann denken sie sich, verdammt, wenn ich jetzt tatsächlich mit dem Programm arbeiten will, was soll ich dann drücken?
Diese Dateien nicht löschen? Ja nein.
Das ist ja noch relativ einfach. Bevor wir uns weiter verstricken, die letzte halbe Stunde will natürlich noch genutzt werden. Ihr könnt weiter anrufen, 031 70 97 110. Bei uns sonst an dieser Stelle kleines Basiswissen in Sachen Nachrichten.
Wenn Fritz im Berliner Kabel, dann 89, 85.
Uhrzeit 0, 31 Uhr.
Fritz, Kurzinfo.
Mit dem Wetter nachts vorübergehend gering bewölkt und Abkühlung auf 3 bis 0 Grad. Tagsanfangsgebiet weise Regen oder Schneeregen, später wieder Schauer 6 bis 9 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Dörner.
Bundeskanzler Schröder sieht derzeit keinen Anlass für eine Debatte über einen Militärschlag gegen den Irak. Erst wenn die Bedingungen und die Beweislage auftreten, die zum Krieg in Afghanistan geführt hätten, könne man darüber reden, sagte er in Berlin. Sollte sich die Lage ändern, werde Deutschland von den USA konsultiert, versicherte der Kanzler. Aus dem Nahen Osten wird ein erneuter Selbstmordanschlag gemeldet. Nahe einer jüdischen Siedlung im Westjordanland sprengte sich eine palästinensische Frau in die Luft, als ihr Wagen kontrolliert werden sollte. Dabei kamen die Attentäterin und zwei Komplizen ums Leben. Brandenburgs Innenminister Schönboben bleibt bei seinem Nein zum geplanten Zuwanderungsgesetz. Der Märkischen Allgemeinen sagte er, in der vorliegenden Form könne die Landesregierung dem Gesetz im Bundesrat nicht zustimmen. UNO-Generalsekretär Anand hat schockiert auf Berichte reagiert, nach denen Mitarbeiter von Hilfsorganisationen Flüchtlingskinder in Westafrika sexuell missbraucht haben. Er habe weitere Nachforschungen angeordnet. Eine Studie hatte ergeben, dass bis zu 70 zumeist einheimische Mitarbeiter von Hilfsorganisationen als Gegenleistung für Lebensmittel Sex verlanken. In der Affäre um die Bankgesellschaft Berlin wurden die ehemaligen AUBIS-Geschäftsführer Neuling und Wienholdt erneut festgenommen. Beide wurden dem Haftrichter vorgeführt. Es bestehe Fluchtgefahr hieß es. Zum Sportfußball in der Champions League gewann Arsenal London gegen Bayern Leverkusen 4 zu 1. In der Deutschen Eishockey-Liga verloren die Eisbären Berlin in München 3 zu 4 nach dem Penalty-Schießen. Es gibt keine aktuellen Meldungen zum Verkehr.
Das Darausgebot 2002. Live in Concert im März. Fettes Brot und Sascha.
Kylie Minogue und die Toten Hosen.
Die nächsten Konzerte.
Fettes Brot.
Am 14. März in der Berliner Kolumbial.
And Sascha am 15. März in der Arena Berlin. Das Darausgebot 2002. Mehr Infos musst du klicken.
www.fritz.de Sascha Fettes Brot.
Kylie Minogue und die Toten Hosen.
Und im Radio.
Die musst du besagen.
Gleich Country-esque beim Chaosradio Aufritz. Wir haben es noch, naja, 20 Minuten, 22 Minuten haben wir noch Zeit, bis zum Ende des heutigen Blue Moons. Es geht um Spam und ist ja schon eine Menge bei rumgekommen. Unter anderem die Einsicht, dass Spam eigentlich überall stattfindet und wahrscheinlich auch demnächst unsere Handys erreicht. Und wir wollen noch ein paar Hörerfragen beantworten. Deswegen könnt ihr unter 0331 70 97 110 eben solche stellen oder bitte, und das ist vielleicht sogar das Wichtigere, Tipps geben dahingehend, wie man das Ganze verhindern kann und dann auch direkt eure eigenen Antworten geben. Am Telefon ist der Andreas.
Also ich wollte mal sagen, also mich stört persönlich auch der Spam, aber es gibt, wie gesagt, schlimmeres meines Erachtens. Also ich schieb's bei mir gleich im Papierkorb und ich würde mir nicht die Mühe machen, wie der Vorredner, jetzt stundenlang, da die mir jetzt noch zu beantworten und da den Leuten irgendwie den selber, den Postfach zuzumachen. Weil es bringt sowieso nichts, weil die Ingenie oder das sowieso nicht schlimmer ist und von daher.
Na, er hat vor allem über's Usenet geredet. Da ist das schon ein bisschen was anderes.
Ja, mag sein, mag sein. Aber wie gesagt, bei mir persönlich, ich krieg jeden Tag beruflich viel mit dabei zu tun. Und da kommen jeden Tag so, schätze ich mal, 40, 50 Werbe-Mails, Spam. Und die wandern immer gleich im Papierkorb. Ich hab mir da auch, ehrlich gesagt, schon abgewöhnt, mir darüber Gedanken zu machen, warum die sowieso werfen und mich darüber aufzuregen.
Ja, sicherlich. Aber es wäre schon schöner, wenn sie nicht da wären, oder?
Es wäre schöner, aber zu Hause habe ich auch einen ganzen Papierkorb voll mit irgendwelchen komischen Werbezetteln. Die kriegen ja auch unaufgefordert. Das ist auch nicht schön, finde ich. Aber ehrlich gesagt, viel schlimmer als E-Mailserbung, weil die kann ich einfach löschen, ohne dass mir das jetzt großartig wehtut.
Und ist dir schon mal passiert, dass du was gelöscht hast, was gar keine Spam war, sondern eine E-Mail an dich?
Nee, noch nicht.
Bist du dir sicher?
Ziemlich sicher.
Wie soll man sich das denn merken? Wenn man sie gelöscht hat, ist sie halt weg.
Ja, aber es gab zum Beispiel eine Magde von mir, die die ganze Sache im Papierkorb aufbewahre immer. Also bei gelöschten Objekten, wenn man drin lasse. Und dann immer erst nach einem Jahr aufräume. Und dann meistens noch mal durch die ganzen E-Mails. Warum auch immer.
Und deine Firma hat denn Mail-Server im Internet?
Ja, im Internet, ja.
Und hat sich da mal mit dem Mühe gemacht, mal auszurechnen, was das so kostet? Das Spam?
Naja, nicht wirklich. Weil wir bezahlen den Traffic vom Pop-Postfach zu uns, bezahlen wir nicht. Und wie gesagt, den Rest haben wir praktisch inklusive. Wir haben dann einen eigenen Server stehen und also der E-Mail Account verursacht im Prinzip keine extra Kosten. Also Kosten an sich nicht zu vernachlässigen, mal verachten.
Und die Zeit, die ihr täglich darauf verwendet, euch damit zu befassen?
Mit der E-Mail auszusortieren oder?
Ja.
Puh, also mittlerweile hat man ja so ein Augefühl, wie es zum meisten schon betrifft, dass es nicht für dich ist. Ich schätze, eine Viertelstunde brauchst du bestimmt.
Eine Viertelstunde pro Tag?
Ungefähr, ja.
Das heißt, wenn zehn Leute, die vielleicht nicht ganz so gut damit klarkommen?
Ja, ist klar. Also es ist schon Arbeitszeit. Klar. In dem Sinne sind auch Kosten. Aber, Gott, ich meine, kannst du wahrscheinlich nicht ändern. Ich würde es wahrscheinlich eher stellen, wenn ich eine Cofenny-Kamera in Sperrwurm kriegen würde.
Das stimmt dir bestimmt nicht bevor.
Ja, hoffentlich nicht. Da muss ich mir wirklich eine neue Handyform mal besorgen.
Ich würde mir da keine Hoffnung machen, um ehrlich zu sein.
Wobei du dabei noch ganz gute Chancen hast, dagegen vorzugehen.
Ich wollte aber noch mal was sagen zu dem Vorredner. Ich bin jetzt auch schon ziemlich lange damit. Ich habe auch viel mit Newsgroups gemacht. Das mache ich mittlerweile überhaupt gar nicht mehr. Weil mich das irgendwann auch ein bisschen genervt hat. Diese ganze Netiquette, Etiquette. Mir ist immer aufgefallen, wenn ein neuer User dazukommt, wurde der gleich zugepostet mit irgendwelchen Newbie-Guys. Da wurde dann immer gleich gesagt, das und das und das. Die Leute wurden meist schon abgeschreckt, bevor sie das erste Wort gesagt haben.
Auch nicht alles. Perfekte Kommunikationsmenschen. Na ja, es gibt auf beiden Seiten da Probleme, sowohl von den neuen Usern als auch von denen, die schon lange dabei sind und können sich alle nicht benehmen. Das lernen wir auch regelmäßig bei uns in unseren News Groups. Also in unseren, wo sich mehr unser Umfeld sammelt. Und da sind sie genauso verbohrt.
Da gibt es auch ein paar Kandidaten.
Die sind zugeflamt und gehen auch jedes Mal komplett an die Decke, wenn wieder irgendwas vollständig Belangloses passiert ist. Eigentlich passiert es auch jedem von uns irgendwann mal, dass wir total austillen und dann die Mail schreiben, die wir eigentlich nie hätten schreiben sollen.
Deswegen kann jedem mal passieren. Mittlerweile hat es für mich schon fast einen kultischen Status angenommen. Dass man wirklich drauf achtet, wie man seinen Namen schreibt, ob das alles super korrekt ist und wie man es so formell macht. Was ich gut finde? Einen lockeren Umgangston in so einer News-Skope. Ich hasse das, wenn Leute sinnlos sind posten, aber sie ignorieren einfach. Also mich da jetzt großartig darauf einlassen und mich mit denen noch rumstreiten über irgendwelche Sachen. Das bringt sowieso nicht, weil dann wird der Trieb 500 Posts lang. Oder dass wir am Ende sagen, so ist man alle Arschloch. Und das ist sowieso Quatsch. Ein vernünftiger Umgangston. Meist merkst du eh schon die Leute, mit denen du vernünftig umgehen kannst. Mit denen du dich auch privat vernünftig mählen kannst.
Aber jetzt mal ganz im Ernst, bei dieser ganzen clicky-Bulti-Gesellschaft und Windows XP-mäßigem Auftreten in letzter Zeit ist doch wahrscheinlich das Interesse eher zum Sterben verurteilt, sage ich mal, was diese News-Groups anbelangt, oder? Warum sollte irgendwie der klassische 12-Jährige da reingehen und sich da lustig machen? Man muss halt immer noch schreiben, oder?
Ja, das ist für den noch nichts, meines Erachtens. Die sind immer an irgendwelche Foren, sind auf irgendwelche anderen Seiten. Also jetzt nicht klassische News-Groups in dem Sinne. Aber was mir zum Beispiel aufgefallen ist, wo du mich ganz unrecht hast, das hört sich jetzt ein bisschen blöd an, aber wir sind... Wir sind bei Ebay immer aufgefahren, ich bin schon ewig und seit halb bei Ebay und in letzter Zeit habe ich jetzt nur ziemlich viele Idioten zu tun da. Also, die dann Sachen kaufen und dann irgendwie nicht klarkommen damit irgendwie. Oder bei denen ich was gekauft habe, die mir das nicht verkaufen oder so, die irgendwie völlig idiotisch mich da noch bewerten oder so. Also das hat mir zum Beispiel umgefallen, das hat in letzter Zeit ziemlich oft passiert. Und nicht nur mir, auch vielen Bekannten, die dann sagen, ok, ich habe hier schon wieder so einen völlig sinnlosen...
Da spricht sich langsam rum. Also die Idioten sammeln sich, das ist ganz offensichtlich. Ich will sogar fast davor warnen, dass demnächst ein Terroranschlag kommt.
Idioten aller Welt, versprengt euch bitte wieder, könnte man ja so formulieren. Der Hannes ist am Telefon, hallo Hannes. Wir sind heute in Sowellen unterwegs, immer mal wieder Mail-Spam und dann wieder zurück zu Instant Messenger. Du hast was zur ICQ.
Jo und zwar, ich habe so eine ICQ-Alternative gefunden im Netz.
Und voran nennt sie sich Trillen.
Wie nennt sie sich wie?
Trillen, also T-R-I-L-L-I-I.
Entschuldigung heißt es.
Und was macht Trillen?
Ja, da kannst du ganz normal, also ICQ übernehmen, deinen ganzen Kontext da. Du kriegst keinen Spam mehr. Seitdem ich es küsste, krieg ich nicht ein bisschen Spam mehr. Du kannst es auch noch für IRC, AIM, MSN, Yahoo nutzen. Das ist alles in dem Programm mit drin.
Es ist auf jeden Fall ein voll geiles Design.
Und ich find's im Prinzip sehr viel besser als ICQ. Und wie gesagt, du hast halt den ganzen Spam nicht mehr. Wiss ich nicht, E-Mail, Express und Video, alle hießen. Gibt's ja nicht mehr.
Naja, wobei das grundsätzlich doch eigentlich relativ blöde ist, sich dann noch bei allen anderen Messengern, die diverse Freunde und Freundinnen auch noch haben, anzumelden. Das heißt, dass man gleich das fünffache Risiko hat, weil der das alles ja gleichzeitig abfragt, oder nicht?
Nö, du kannst es ausschalten.
Ist dir überlassen.
Also du kannst jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, geh jetzt nur mit ECQ rein oder mach gleichzeitig noch, weiß nicht, AOL und MSN auf, oder so.
Naja, ich hab festgestellt, ich hab das mal runtergeladen für Mac. Da gibt's auch so einen Teil. Das heißt irgendwie Fire Application, na na. Und Tatsache ist, dass die meisten so stylisch aufgebaut sind und so cool und so minimal, dass man, wenn man...
Ist dein Computer auch tiefer gelegt?
Ja, sicher, natürlich. Klar. Macht auch richtig geil Kraft.
Roller?
Spoiler?
Also ich hab einen Einspritzer.
Ja.
Das ist halt eine geile Sache. Und ich hab mir die Düsen aufbohren lassen.
Auf dem Prozessor? Du hast Düsen auf dem Prozessor?
Sicher.
Geil.
So klar, so jenseits. Ja, schon eine geile Kiste. Jedenfalls ergibt's dafür auch diese Programme. Und Tatsache ist, dass die immer ein bisschen schwierig zu verstehen sind für Anfänger, weil die voraussetzen, dass man die anderen Programme alle schon kennt.
Also ich find's eigentlich ganz easy.
Also bei ECQ, vor allen Dingen, das Daten dauert viel länger, bei ECQ das Schreiben. Du hast bei Trillen gar nichts, du hast keine Werbung, nichts.
Also ich find's auf jeden Fall besser, cooler aufgebaut.
Du kannst dir Skins runterladen, die die Form verändern und alles.
Entschuldigung, wie war dein Name noch? Hannes. Ich meine, hast du auch ein Spam-Problem?
Okay, fassen wir noch mal zusammen, das Tool heißt Trillium und schreibt sich Trillien. Und man kann das auch unter dem Namen runterladen. Aber wie gesagt, da sei vorgewarnt, weil ich glaube nicht, dass die so cool geschrieben sind, dass die eben verhindern, dass man dann von allen Anbietern, die man da benutzt, gleichzeitig auch noch Spam bekommt.
Ja, ich hab eine Frage in der Richtung. Zwar nicht direkt spammen, aber im erweiterten Sinne schon. Und zwar sind ja nur hoch allerhand Anbieter in Richtung Pet-Mails und Petstart und was in der Richtung ist.
Pet, Entschuldigung, welche Richtung meinst du noch mal?
Wo man zum Beispiel jetzt ganz konkret von bestimmten Anbietern E-Mails sich bewusst zukommen lässt und dafür, um die Werbung anzuschauen, Geld bekommt dafür.
Ah, verstehe. Daran hast du teilgenommen?
Ich muss sagen, sogar teilweise mit Erfolg, ja.
Mit welchem Erfolg hast du Geld bekommen?
Richtig.
Wie viel?
Ist unterschiedlich. Also amerikanische Anbieter gehen ja erst ab 20 Dollar los. Der Austahlungsgrenze in Deutsche ab 5 Euro. Also 50% Erfolgsrate, muss man sagen.
Sekunde mal reißt du jetzt.
Was musst du genau tun?
Im Prinzip sich dort anmelden. Und dann bekommt man zielgerichtet Werbung, so wie man das einstellt, so wie man das haben möchte. Und für das Betrachten der Werbung bekommt man dann Geld. Unterschiedlich pro Mail zwischen 1 Cent bis hin zu 30 Cent.
Und wie wird das Betrachten überprüft? Wie wird das Betrachten überprüft?
Da ist ein Beschädigungsklick oben.
Das heißt, in deiner Software befindet sich so ein Button und dann sagst du, habe ich gelesen.
Richtig.
Welche Software ist das? Welche Software verwendest du, um E-Mails zu lesen?
Das mach ich meistens über AOL direkt.
Ah, das läuft im Browser dann sozusagen.
Im Browser oder mit der AOL Zugangssoftware?
Im Browser.
Welchen Browser?
Was für eine AOL-Geboe, nehm den Link hoch in den Browser, kopier den rein und bestell dir den.
Und du hast auch für...
Wie viel Geld hast du bekommen, um wie viel E-Mails durchzulesen?
Also, wenn man jetzt ohne die Referral-Links rechnet, rechnet sich das nicht, muss man auch so sagen.
Nee, ich hab nicht gefragt, ob sich das rechnet, sondern um wie viel Geld handelt es sich?
Also im Monat so ungefähr 200 Dollar.
200 Dollar?
Und was musstest du dafür tun?
Na, ungefähr rund, kann man sagen, sind es fast 1500 mehr.
Ach du dickes Ei.
1500 E-Mails, die musstest du dir durchlesen?
Nee, bloß bestätigen. Viele brauchen wir gar nicht lesen, viele bestätigen sich auch automatisch, viele sind auch dann praktisch direkt als interaktiv, wo man bloß draufklickt. Also es ist unterschiedlich, es ist ganz unterschiedlich hier angebietet.
Also ich frage mich ja die ganze Zeit, was die eigentlich messen. Also ich meine, du hast nicht zwei Buttons, wo du sagst, die finde ich toll, die habe ich verstanden, sondern du sagst einfach nur, die habe ich gelesen.
Na sie lesen die Views. Das ist der Sinn der Anzeigengesellschaft oder dieser Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie da draus. Man bezahlt dafür, dass jemand seine Augen auf das von allen platzierte Werbeobjekt richtet. Bisher macht man das, indem man große Summen Geld an Tageszeitungen gibt, damit die Plakate ausrollen und davon abwucken.
Und ich meine, hat das irgendeine Wirkung auf dich gehabt? Hast du angefangen, irgendwelche Produkte zu kaufen, die in diesen Mails, die du gelesen hast, beworben wurden?
Nein, aber es ist dieselbe Wirkung wie die Fernsehwerbung. Wo es nur den Unterschied hat, dass man hier eben noch Taschenwerden in den Bein kriegt.
Mir tut mein Handgelenk total weh seitdem. Das ist der Effekt, weil du dauernd klicken musst.
Das stimmt, aber wie gesagt, ist es halt nicht ganz umsonst.
Aber super. Also die ganz dumm sind doch im Grunde die Firmen, weil ich meine, diese Geschichte wird wahrscheinlich jeder Zweite so machen. Das heißt, ich guck mir 1500 Werbemails an, kann natürlich keine verarbeiten und die Firma gibt wahrscheinlich doch schon eine Menge Geld dafür aus.
Bestimmt billiger als Printwerbung.
Wie viel Zeit verwendest du auf das Lesen dieser E-Mails pro Tag? Zwei Stunden pro Tag.
Das heißt, du lässt dich bei 200?
Im Monat bekommst du 200 Dollar.
Das sind 10 Dollar-Stundenlohn am Tag. Nein, das sind 5, weil du zwei Stunden brauchst. Also verdienst man ja 5 Euro pro Stunde, damit du Mails liest.
Richtig, kann man so ein paar Schale sagen, ja.
Kann man das während der klassischen Arbeit, die man sowieso tut, erledigen, oder ist das ein Fulltime-Job?
Nee, das mach ich nur nebenbei. Ich setze mich grundsätzlich zwei Stunden meine privaten Mails. Da hab ich auch einen Anbieter, der sogar für die Mails, die ich verschicke, Geld zahlt. Und das andere lasse ich dann so in den Background nebenbei hochladen.
Wie heißt der Anbieter? MISC?
So ein MISC. Könnte man auch sagen.
Und glaubst du nicht, dass die irgendwie merken, wenn die da jemand bescheißt? Also wenn jemand irgendwie ein Programm schreibt, was immer diesen Knopf drückt oder so?
Die haben da auch keine Resonanz, wenn sie im Fernsehen oder in der Zeitung. Das kostet noch viel mehr, Fernsehwerbung. Was sie da für Rückläufer kriegen.
Denen ist es doch auch egal. Die geben ihre Kontaktpreise ohnehin nur an den Kunden. Von dem kriegen sie das Geld und der kann das erst recht nicht kontrollieren. Deswegen, die Firma selber wird eigentlich ganz gut verdienen.
Das wird entschieden Preiswetter sein als Fernsehwerbung.
Ist es?
Du wusstest eben, dass da an den Kunden, der mit Werbung bombardiert wird, was er im Fernsehen, wenn er nicht gerade PTV hat, nicht beeinflussen kann. Hier kann man es noch beeinflussen.
Also ich finde das irgendwie auch gut. Wenn man Werbung wirklich empfangen will, dafür auch noch Geld zu bekommen, das man jetzt anschaut, ist eigentlich gar keine schlechte Alternative zu spammen.
Da könnte man auch sein Kind dran setzen, ne?
Also ich habe meinen späten Rechner, habe ich im Prinzip nur damit gelassen, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Da ist ein Bildschirmschoner oben, der Geld bringt. Das Einzige, was jetzt ist, diese Inet war, da ist in einer Firma, die richtig gut gezahlt hat, Bankrott gegangen, die wahrscheinlich zu gut gezahlt haben. Aber das schleppert sich zusammen.
Sagen wir mal, ist der ganze Computer zu Hause, der läuft ausschließlich Software, die dazu führt, dass du irgendwie pro Stunde bezahlt wirst?
Richtig, richtig.
Die haben mir im Prinzip meinen... Ja, zumindest in der Online-Zeit, dass die Fetträder rauskommen und dass, wie gesagt, das Taschengeld und der Strompreis nebenbei auch noch rauskommt.
Und die Werbung, die da gezeigt wurde, hattest du das Gefühl, die war anspruchsvoll?
Ist gemischt, muss ich sagen. Das meiste, was jetzt kommt, weil die Amerikaner, die tummeln sich unwahrscheinlich da drinnen und das alles in Englisch ist und das ist nicht so und nicht so ansprechend. Aber bestimmte deutsche Anbieter, die sind richtig gut aufgemacht, ja.
Also weil es gibt ja mittlerweile auch schon so zielgruppengerechtete Werbung, gerichtete Werbung. Und du kannst dir vorstellen, dass jetzt eine Zielgruppe, die irgendwie zwei Stunden vor dem Rechner sitzt und irgendwie Werbung wegklickt, dann wahrscheinlich eher für die, naja, nicht so anspruchsvollen Angebote in Frage kommt. Deswegen frag ich.
Ja, also richtig anspruchsvolle sind relativ wenig dabei.
Nochmal was Anspruchsvolles, was Anspruchsvolle Werbung ist.
Wer Anspruchsvolle Werbung bietet eigentlich, das ist ein deutscher Anbieter, das hier nennt sich unter mehr Geld verdient, 24. Mehr Geld verdient, 24.
Das ist auch so ein typischer Internet-Ekonomie.
Bei der Ami lacht man sich noch mehr kaputt. Cash-ID und Rapid-E-Mail und Real Deal und Dollar-Depot. Die haben alle so komische Namen.
Da lernt man wenigstens was dabei.
Bei den Amis-Talen erwartet man es irgendwie, wenn es hier auch noch losgeht, nichts mehr zu retten.
Man lernt zumindest, damit man überhaupt guckt, wo man sich anmeldet, sich der englische Sprache zu vervollkommnen. Damit man da nicht aufs falsche Feld klickt. Ja.
W-W-W, du wärst ganz schön blöd, wenn du diese Seite nicht anklickst.
Ja, das sind auch so bestimmte Sachen. Wie gesagt, viele bieten auch an. Es geht ja letztendlich um Spams auch. Viele schreiben rüber, no Spams und dann ganz kleiner Text dazu. Falls dieses Feld nicht aktiviert wird, dann wird man eben doch zugeballert. Da muss man eben auch aufpassen.
Okay. So viel für alle, die sich vielleicht im professionellen Bereich in die Werbeempfangsszene eingliedern wollen. Dank dir, Ramiro.
Alles klar.
Vielleicht ist ja Christian noch am Telefon.
Hallo, Christian.
Christian? Christian ist nicht mehr da. Das ist aber auch okay, weil das war noch ein letzter Tipp in Sachen, was man denn alles so machen könnte. Eigentlich relativ resignative Stimmung macht, gesehen davon, dass man sich natürlich köstlich amüsieren kann mit diesem Thema. Also viel machen kann man ja nun wirklich nicht.
Ja, man kann schon den notwendigen Aufwand treiben, der einem weitgehend die Sache vom Hals hält. Ist ja nicht so, dass es einen nun wirklich dermaßen nervt, dass es nichts Wichtiges gäbe auf diesem Planeten. Aber es zeigt eben auch, wie wichtig das ist, in diesem Netz eine gewisse Kultur auch weiterzuentwickeln. Die gibt es teilweise schon und erinnert sich natürlich auch immer wieder. Und man kann einfach das Netz sehr viel effektiver und gewinnbringend dann nicht nur im finanziellen Sinne, sondern auch im kulturellen Sinne benutzen, wenn man einfach bestimmte Regeln beachtet oder sich zumindest bereit erklärt, mit anderen Leuten sich auch welche zu einigen.
Aber jetzt mal so abschließend eine Einschätzung für die Zukunft. Weil vorhin auch mal noch mal der Begriff Mailbox-System viel, dass bestimmte Leute sich halt immer noch in so abgeschlossenen Netzen bewegen. Wie hoch ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es sowas wieder geben wird, einfach um sich vor dem ganzen anderen Kram schützen zu können, dass man sich nur da ein wenig keinen Zugang zum Internet hat und halt ein großes Angebot von einem großen Anbieter bekommt?
Na ja, erst mal solche geschlossenen Diskussionsgruppen und Mailverteiler, das gibt es ja zuhauf. Und wird es auch immer wieder geben. Die Mailbox-Szene ist schon weitgehend im Internet aufgegangen, aber formt natürlich innerhalb des Internets auch einen bestimmten Anwendungstyp. Es gibt schon so Mailboxen, die Internettechnologie benutzen, aber im Prinzip das gleiche Benutzungsgruppenverhalten aufweisen. Ganz klar. Und das wird sich auch weiterentwickeln. Letzten Endes ist die Frage, wie man E-Mail als Dienst, der ja nun mindestens so wichtig ist wie das Telefon, wie man den einfach frei halten kann. Wenn die Leute heutzutage auf ihrem Telefon genauso viele Anrufe von irgendwelchen Leuten mit Werbung bekommen würden, wie sie eine E-Mail bekommen haben, dann wäre hier der Teufel los. Und wenn man das einfach mal aufs Internet überträgt, ist eigentlich auch jeder einzelne E-Mail, mit der ich einfach nichts zu tun haben will, weil ich hab's mir nicht bestellt, ich will nichts wissen über die Scheißprodukte. Wenn diese E-Mail einfach eintrifft, dann ist es für mich auch genauso nervig, weil ich muss dagegen arbeiten, ich muss mir selber mit diesen komplizierten Techniken vertraut machen und das will man natürlich einfach nicht.
Abschließend noch eine Frage, die mir spontan in den Sinn kommt. Was ist eigentlich mit Blinken-Lights?
Hatten wir das nicht schon als Thema?
Klar, aber ich kenn's die Leute doch. Schon wieder aus den Augen, aus dem Sinn.
Wo geht's weiter?
Pfff, gucken wir mal.
Blinken-Lights ist tot, ist lebe... Das war das Chaosradio zum Thema Spam und alles, was dranhängt, für manche mehr, für manche weniger. Mit Andreas, Frank, Tim und Host Malodky im Studio. Und wir sagen soweit Tschüss und Danke. Und bis zum nächsten letzten Mittwoch im Monat.
Ein Gemeinschaftsprogramm von ORB und SFB produziert in Babelsberg.